a couple nights ago I was talking we had
uh actually when was this it was last
week Jack Murphy was on the podcast and
I think we were talking about
Mandalorian and I said I you know I give
it like a c plus I enjoyed the first
season it's okay but not good enough to
where I was like oh I gotta watch season
two and then he said no no trust me like
it gets better and I was like all right
I'll watch it so I started watching
these episodes and I really do enjoy the
show I think it's great and I think uh
Gina Carano particularly does a great
job as Cara Dune well as most of you
know she has been canceled fired over
what is like a pretty mild post that
actually was I mean she was basically
saying don't demonize your neighbor well
any excuse for the woke mob to destroy
someone for whatever reason and it was
taken and now now it's not just about
the criticism over cancel culture it
turns out Pedro Pascal the lead of the
show had a very similar tweet in 2018
where he compared or he was trying to
compare the United States to World War
II Germany the only problem what people
are saying and I'm not sure I've in fact
it's a fact check this so check me check
me on this one the image he posted
wasn't even from America it was 2010 and
it wasn't even kids in cages because the
door was like open it was just some
nonsensical you know virtue signal but
that was fine for Gina Carano to say Hey
you know don't demonize your neighbor
that's what they did in World War II
Germany they're like that is important
how dare you defend Republicans and thus
she's been fired from from lucasfilms
which she was also supposed to get like
another show they were reporting also
dropped from her agency United Talent
which is one of the biggest agencies
that's huge
so we got a big cancel culture episode
for you guys today because we've got
Mass censorship we've got you know
there's this documentary that got pulled
down I don't know a whole lot about it
and I'm not here to praise it or
criticize it just talk about the removal
it's called Planet lockdown the media
says it was a conspiracy theory document
but I got 20 million views before it was
removed and now we don't even know what
was being set so we're going to talk
about all this stuff and other things
like what apparently Biden wanted some
restrictions on Florida because Florida
is releasing the lockdown it's going to
get spicy but joining us today we have
an awesome uh guest the ultra famous
Blair white hi I wore a beanie just for
you to be on brand to be honest
beautiful yeah yeah well it's it is
mandatory but Luke and Ian just
continually defy the world the law we're
rebellious do you want to just give a
brief introduction for people who might
not know you yeah sure I'm a YouTuber
internet personality I guess been around
since 2016.
um I do a lot of commentary on culture
and you and I have kind of ran in the
same circles for a few years so is this
our first time doing something on camera
together I think so because we were I
think we were at event once yeah it was
the miscon thing yeah we hung out in La
once
oh that was like on 2017 Halloween yes
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah right
on those were the days so uh yeah you
got a big YouTube channel and uh we'll
talk about stuff we also got to Lou
gradkowski I refused the beanie yes
welcome back beautiful and amazing human
beings my name is lucrative we are
change.org and I have upgraded I am no
longer just the T-shirt vendor I am a
vendor of a bunch of things board games
customized probiotics water filters you
name it and if you're interested in some
of those products and want to support me
you can on we are change.org forward
slash donate and because you do I'm here
and thank you very much for having me
nice plug yeah that was good subscribe
to my channel
so glad you're here early adopter of
Mines technology helping us kind of I
don't you didn't know that I was
involved with it at the time yeah free
speech all the way hey and uh oh I was
gonna ask do you have Twitter I was
gonna shout out your name on Twitter I
don't know somehow I still have Twitter
I don't know how I'm not married let me
knock on wood where's your Twitter it's
Ms Blair white Ms blairway thanks a lot
and uh shout out to the kombucha this is
the pineapple basil sorry
sorry I'm here in the corner pushing
buttons thank you you guys so uh I I
think I think on a launch of my own uh
pillow company and I think I'm gonna
call it our pillow yes so I'm jokingly
going to make a pillow like not a legit
company but just like as a merch just
because you know what it's time for a
the real criticism of my pillow is that
it's my pillow no our pillow that's
right we're in this together but let's
let's we'll talk about cancel culture
before we do head over to timcast.com
become a member because we've got some
pretty serious stuff that we just put up
we did an after Show members only
exclusive uh segment with Matt Brainerd
we had on last night talking about well
let me just read the title Matt Brainerd
announces report on illegal ballots in
Georgia and explains the results and we
get I I don't know we may have said
things that YouTube would actually ban
so we wanted to make sure that uh it was
on the website if you want to watch it
become a member and there's this uh I'll
I'll be careful with what I say because
you know YouTube is Ban happy we're
literally talking about cancel culture
and the threat where we try and speak
freely they'll nuke you so we have no
choice but to put it on the website
however the the future we will have free
content just for the time being we don't
actually have it set up that way so but
if you become a member you'll get access
to all of these uh podcast episodes
segments Etc that being said uh one more
time timcast.com like share subscribe
this video let's talk about the latest
news with lucasfilm you guys maybe have
heard because it's been the no the
number one trending story last night
after we did the show we have this from
variety lucasfilm and United Talent drop
Mandalorian star Gina Carano following
offensive social media posts I'm sorry I
don't think the posts well look I guess
offensive is in the eye of the beholder
I suppose but she basically made a post
it looked like she was quoting someone
else who said that in World War II
Germany they pitted neighbor against
neighbor and that's what gave the you
know the political party there I would
just say the Nazis the ability to then
round people up they got the people of
the country all angry they were
demagoguing the crazy thing about what
she posted is it's exactly what the left
has been complaining about with Donald
Trump they said Donald Trump is a
demagogue who is villainizing people and
tearing us apart so then Gina Chrono is
basically like yeah you know what that's
what they did in World War II Germany we
shouldn't do this and they were like oh
you bigot ban her well the big news the
big update is that well Disney's kind of
getting slammed because Pedro Pascal did
something very similar and he's the star
of the show so he's able to post these
comparisons claiming the US is like Nazi
Germany nobody cares this should be just
proof to anybody that we're dealing with
with Hypocrites who don't actually care
about what they're saying it is absolute
BS and uh I canceled I canceled my
Disney plus you got you guys cancel
Disney plus I never got it I don't have
it I use my friends
I don't know but I think what's
interesting is that she didn't even
mention leftists Or democrats or the
left in her post unless I'm mistaken no
no there's nothing like that so it's
kind of like if the shoe fits like if
someone's talking about Nazis and you
get mad you might be a Nazi right uh and
and like you said the entirety of the
left has been making Nazi comparisons
for the past four or five years over
Trump and over right Wingers in general
why did they fire Gina Carano like I've
been thinking about this all day because
I recorded a segment earlier in the
morning it can't be for the stated
reason maybe they just didn't want her
like they wanted to find a reason to
fire her and they were like oh here's
our that's our chance well she's been an
undercover Hollywood conservative for a
minute I remember back and I think it
was August or September they were trying
to get her back then too because she
made some kind of post about uh pronouns
yeah she made a Boop on beat post
um and uh which I thought was funny is
it a meme or something or is this
um it was she was making fun of like R2
D2 yeah and saying that was the pronoun
it was funny she also posted about
individuals like Epstein and as you know
a lot of people in Hollywood and
government are usually connected to
individuals like that and you know it's
just absolutely scary and dangerous
what's happening because it's so
orwellian it's so backwards we have
unaccountable billionaire corporate
Executives deciding which speech is okay
and which which speech they should
censor because it's dangerous when in
reality them doing that is dangerous and
it's absolutely ridiculous but that's
why I'm saying I don't think I I feel
like there's something else going on
here yeah of course yeah because what do
you mean well the the boop beep thing
was more offensive you know it was like
it was considered offensive to uh
pronouns or whatever not that not that I
think it was offensive none of it's
offensive everyone is so there must be
something else to I don't get it maybe
she made the wrong people mad yeah
everyone's so just defiant that's what
I'm thinking because you can't fake
offense and there's no way I mean we saw
a little of the kind of like outrage by
the blue check marks yesterday before
the major decision was made because we
were talking about actually talking
about this story right before we went on
and uh I didn't think they'd fire her I
didn't think it would go this far and
then after the show I'm like holy cow
they they fired her from the show and
then a lot of actors are pissed off a
lot of people on the show are pissed off
and they should be I mean this is
leading towards this kind of situation
that's going to cause brain drain in one
way or another whether it's people who
wants to come here who are going to be
afraid because people are just getting
canceled because of their opinions that
are milk toast that are not even yes
that wild that are not even that
partisan she was talking about a
historical reference where people were
wild up so much that they started to
hate their neighbor you know something
of course that that many people prove by
the actions today is a legitimate threat
and they proved it they proved it it's
exactly what's happening yeah you know
this reminded me of when uh Luke and I
were in Hamburg Germany for the G20
there was a moment where Luke was just
walking down the street with some just
like a random local journalist and
someone pointed and yelled Nazi
schweinhund at Luke and then random
people who were just sitting nearby
jumped up and random started punching
about you could tell the story better
than I can I mean I even have history my
family fighting the Nazis fighting the
Communists as a polish-born proud person
I'm like why am I in Germany getting
called the Nazi getting attacked and
jumping
but think about this what was
particularly striking about what
happened to you was that there were
people just sitting on the ground like
on the curb and as soon as they heard
the word they jumped up having no idea
who you are or what you were doing and
started beating you and it was brutal
because like it wasn't just like one
group of people it was organized in a
way where I was able to push away get
away and then down the block someone
would hit me and then down the block
someone else would hit me and I'm like I
I can't I have to keep running because
they were everywhere and they were there
was literal squads of individuals with
my photos and a whole team of them
running around not just my photos there
was other journalist independent
journalist mainstream media journalists
that weren't even connected to us they
just had photos taken next to us they
were just our friends that were just
there that had nothing to do and with
anything political they got the crap
beat out of them because they had antifa
hit squads literally looking at photos
running through all the crowds that's
not the issue right the issue is that
there were people who didn't have those
photos who were just like there's there
was like a guy and he's like sitting on
the ground eating chips and then as soon
as they hear someone yell Nazi he runs
up and starts hitting Luke having no
idea why he's doing it what I see with
what Gina Carano posted and and then
what happens now still with the same
it's the same thing I don't care if
they're fascists or anti-fascists they
seem to love to just randomly beat
people they don't know yeah granted one
was substantially worse we're trying to
stop the authoritarians from moving in
this direction why because Disney fires
Gina Carano while thanking the
paramilitary group in in xinjiang that
is running uyghur concentration camps
right so forgive me if you're like how
dare you compare antifa to the fascists
well the antifa people apparently are
cheering on Disney who is thanking the
paramilitary group running a
concentration camp of a religious
minority so it kind of feels like we're
getting dangerously close to some real
world parallel and she proved it today
with her post and and lucasfilm released
the statement and they said her Twitter
posts were quote adhorrent and
unacceptable I mean are you kidding me
and those are the statements that of
course Twitter of course ran with so
whenever you clicked on the story it
said Gino was fired for adhorrent social
media post and of course they don't they
don't mention they don't list what the
post was and when you really look at it
Jeffrey Epstein this beep bop thing this
this you know Nazi com comparison not
even not even comparison but just saying
hey this happened during history we
shouldn't let it happen now hold on
wasn't Walt Disney like a raging
anti-semite it was yes yes
well there you go he's offended that
Disney's offended because she's calling
them out yeah if anyone should be
canceled it's this for their
participation with the with the uyghur
Muslim police force their time their
ties with Walt Disney of all people and
you know the their their cartoons also
have a long history that that's very
controversial there's a lot of things we
could bring up I mean if we're gonna do
anything not just cancel your membership
cancel Disney all in general if you want
to play by these rules cancel all of
these people yeah yeah I always tell my
friend to cancel his account that I'm
using but you know what I wish that
there were more I wish people weren't
such cowards because half of Hollywood
is conservative okay I would say half
generous okay and no one is speaking up
on her behalf that is a conservative in
Hollywood no one and it's like they're
just sitting there hoping that it
doesn't eventually hit them and it's
going to whether it's in February the
summer fall at some point they're going
to get you two because in my opinion
celebrities who don't speak about
politics are always conservatives and we
talked about that earlier it's like if
you're not talking about it you're
probably at least right-leaning and
that's all it takes because like we said
she wasn't even saying anything super
partisan I was in uh I was in LA a
couple years ago and there was some like
b-list celebrity guy and he was talking
to people and someone who was you know
we were out in the street
one of the guys was there was a trump
supporter and so he was talking to the
celebrity and then when everyone started
leaving he's like this dude voted for
Trump and he goes come on come on come
on man don't tell anybody and then he
looked at me he's like dude for sure
yeah but no one can know and I'm like I
get it but like I also hate it yeah that
everyone is so cowardly because at the
end of the day because no one's speaking
up it does make the few people who speak
up they take all of the Heat and I've
always talked about that so it's it's
very frustrating I've always hung out
with some like celebrities whenever I go
to La and all of them treat me like
their secret girlfriend they're like so
don't tell anyone we're you know I'm
like dude you don't even got to tell me
that like I'm like I'm not you know fan
boring or gonna take a picture what you
just relax and calm down like I love
your stuff let's talk about this let's
talk about this I want to know about
this and then they're dying to talk
about it they're dying to talk about it
they love that they have a lot of
passion and I I I'm not gonna you know
tell you exactly who it is but there's a
bunch of them and there's a big
community of people that that have to
literally be quiet about their own
personal beliefs about something that
they truly deep down believe is true
that they can't even openly talk about
because they're scared of getting the
hammer across their head those ideas
will die with them that's it that's the
point if you don't say them they go away
it's like it's like the mask right you
wear the mask so you can't spit the the
coronavirus at people yeah so they're
putting a mask over your ears so that
you can't well actually no it's over
it's literally a digital mask and a
physical mask this is what's really
crazy about what's going on right I
think that I think the reason they got
rid of Gina is not because of this one
post it's because she's a rebel because
she defies the Orthodoxy it's a series
of posts and they're like we cannot have
someone going against us because they
don't want this individual gaining power
they don't want celebrities to go up and
and ferment some kind of revolt against
the establishment but I tell you what's
worrying I mentioned this before you
can't go to a bar the bars are all under
restrictions so people aren't meeting
each other they're not sharing ideas
they're not talking so they go online
but those ideas online that are bad are
filtered out because it's hate speech or
wrong think or whatever so what they're
doing is the longer they stay locked
down
the the more they are controlling
exactly what people think and hear and
say that is so true and you know they so
I live in LA pray for me and they just
started reopening outdoor dining of
course it's freezing no one's eating
Outdoors but along with it was a
stipulation that you couldn't turn the
TV on in restaurants restaurant owners
could not have their TVs on and it's
like it really is about a control of
information a control conversation and
like you said of meeting people
exchanging ideas starting to question
why have I been on my knees begging for
money for the past year from the
government why like maybe the mass thing
doesn't make as much sense as people
think maybe this doesn't make as much
sense it's about control of the
conversation and it's so disturbing
we're gonna get banned Instagram just
said they're going to start Banning
people for hate speech and direct
messages that's not just them I mean we
could list really a whole number of
individuals that were banned that were
hit today but I think the larger context
of why this is happening is this larger
insecurity
a police state that we've seen be the
epitome of the Biden Administration
we've seen them
representatively be surrounded by police
officers trying to look tough and I
think this is another example of this
exemplified with just striking someone
down who wasn't really saying anything
controversial words wasn't saying
anything crazy but this is going to have
a chilling effect not just in Hollywood
but in the larger social media political
Spectrum where people are like well I
don't want my Twitter account taken down
I better not even dare to talk about
history because if I do they're going to
destroy me and I'm going to lose my job
my agency is going to take me down and
and then this is going to reverberate
amongst people and we have to understand
it only works because we let it work
this killing effect this fear this
silencing efforts have been done in many
coordinated ways and this is why for so
many reasons big Tech oligarchs social
media companies like like Twitter
Facebook YouTube they never tell you
exactly why they ban you they never give
you a reason they never give you a way
to even answer yourself or even have a
fair hearing or even have a decision
that you could be held accountable for
no blanket cut no accountability no
translation sentence life sentence
forever deleted from the discourse not
being able to talk ever because why we
don't even know so that's the reason
people don't want to experience that and
and the way I know it's real what people
are feeling that fear that you talked
about is that even I sometimes catch
myself feeling it and I have made a
living off being outspoken on the
internet for years and even I sometimes
before I say something I'm like
should I say that which always makes me
want to say it more but still it's like
imagine the person who is working in
nine to five who is working in a
corporate environment where they can't
say anything you know my fiance is
working at a job where over the summer
um he's not working there anymore so I
can say this now but his job was
donating like a ton of proceeds from the
shoots he was doing he works in
production in Hollywood from money they
made to bailing out Riders and he
couldn't say anything about it he's like
so I'm working this company generating
revenue and they're sending that to
bailout writers who are destroying the
city I'm living in where I'm now unsafe
because they're destroying the city I'm
living in so so that's what it is people
can't say anything Hollywood is funding
terrorists basically yeah you have
people who go around threatening you
they they threaten your business they
threaten your life they destroy it and
then you have these you know these
personalities these faux progressives
who cheer that on right then when they
deploy the National Guard and Mass to DC
to lock the place down these supposed
anti-fascists who think the US
government is this evil empire cheer
that on right what no these are people
who are just they're they're they're
boot lickers but that's probably being
generous they're literally the boot
they're a tool of the state to suppress
what happened to the a cab all cops are
about what happened to that that went
out the window so quick once they were
well the National Guard are cops so true
yeah but an unarmed woman was shot and
killed right and the story now
apparently this this officer from the
capitol wasn't actually hit in the head
yeah they don't know what happened they
think the some reports I saw said they
think it may have been pepper spray well
there's reports of him answering back
and talking to families saying he was
okay and then the next day passing away
and then it's still a mystery because we
don't know what happened and if you look
at the casualty rates I mean there's a
heart attack there's someone being
trampled it's all Trump supporters even
even there's reports of the of the
officer being a trump supporter uh and
still a lot of mystery why can't we find
out what's going on especially if we're
going to be using this event for for
such an example to lead us into this new
political sphere we should understand
what happened here if we're going to use
this as an example and keep talking
about it right you know what I love I
love all of a sudden the the Democrats
like falling over themselves to defend
Mitt Romney there's like a video of Mitt
Romney being ushered to safety and
they're like Mitt Romney was almost hurt
and I'm like is that the first time you
cared about a republican right I think
so I'm old enough to remember the things
that were said about Bush McCain Romney
it's like they treated him and maybe
people that are a little younger than me
I guess I'm not that old don't remember
but they treated them just like Trump
like Romney was racist and sexist and
McCain was racist and sexist I don't
know dog on the car oh I remember that I
remember that he put like a dog carry on
his roof or something yeah
Mitt Romney is awful he is awful but
it's like he's rewriting and suddenly
everyone loves him it's like ugh I can I
can respect that they don't want the man
to get hurt I don't want to get hurt
either I mean I like the guy but I wish
him nothing but safety and you know a
long life and happiness with his family
so I get it but I just love this idea
that people screaming he was a fascist
trying to take over the country in 2012
all of a sudden they're like this poor
man
oh okay we have to understand these are
limited people and their reactions that
benefit the establishment these are a
few people these are not the majority of
people these are not a big
representation of everyone uh you know
there's not that many of them but when
they do speak their voices are elevated
through the algorithms through of course
uh the the news feeds that that curate
and make you see this to spin this
larger divide and conquer cycle and I
think by and large people don't like
this because when you look at the number
one downloaded app in the world right
now can you guys guess what it is
the third one is signal all
communication efforts I heard negative
things about telegram I still have to do
more research about this they've been
accused of censoring post as well and
working with governments I still haven't
been able to verify that I need to do my
own research on that but when you look
at telegram when you look at signal they
represent Communications that are away
from the control of the state away from
the moderators away from the mainstream
media that will censor you and try to
ruin you and take away your job and take
away your existence as a human being in
our society for having the wrong
political opinion and essentially I mean
what we're seeing here is is journalists
some blue check mark individuals being
highlighted promoted by these big Tech
oligarchs that are celebrating the
destruction of someone's career and
that's sick in its own Twisted own way
and the analogy I had here it's it's
like they're smelling blood in the water
but the sharks aren't the journalists
the big Tech billionaires are are the
sharks and the journalists are the
bottom feeders that are eating off the
shark's poop
family-friendly show I was going to say
something else that's the analogy of
what's happening right now uh and and
you know that's why we're seeing even
Mexico propose a law just recently that
would open up big Tech media companies
well fines we'll get into Mexico I think
we should stick to America first because
I want to bring this up this this point
right here who do you think is
responsible for the fact that this all
got really really bad the censorship and
everything first and foremost Adolf
Hitler I'm not going to blame the
victims I think it's the the left the
Democrats the political establishment
they want the censorship progressives
cheered it on and then they started
getting censored going oh no why am I
getting banned well because you
empowered them to do this interestingly
though one of the politicians that we
have Ted Cruz who has been very vocal
about censorship and calling it out said
something very interesting The Blaze
reports Ted Cruz you can blame the Trump
Administration for not reigning in big
Tech censorship bingo I could never get
the people in the administration
executing the policy to get serious
about stopping censorship here here Ted
Cruz wow 100
it was an entire four years in office
and that we had the power a Republicans
have the power I don't know if I
consider myself a republican anymore but
we didn't do anything and it was almost
the biggest complaint we had because it
was just getting worse and worse and
worse I remember every year leading up
to the 2020 election everyone was saying
at least on the right wing sphere was
saying you know that it's going to get
worse and worse and worse and worse and
it just kept going and knowing anything
and and I and many others said Trump
will not win if they don't fight back
and in 2018 I said one of my favorite
the favorite one of my favorite segments
is Republicans are too stupid to stop
censorship and spineless no no no no no
no don't say ignorant because they don't
say ignorant Trump was not ignorant
Trump knew and had everyone around him
all of his core support base screaming
at him hey yeah please we're are getting
obliterated here his core base of
supporters his personalities that kind
of brought him into the situation into
the position where he where he got to be
president all of those core people were
taken out one by one and they were
screaming help help help and then Donald
Trump didn't do nothing and now we're
here today where Twitter just announced
I don't know if you've seen this Twitter
announced that they banned Donald Trump
for Life yes even if everyone decides to
run for president of the United States
Ian I went to the White House with Bill
ottman I'm saying bill ottman before the
people who don't you know because
obviously you know who bill is so I went
with Bill he's the CEO of Mines Ian and
Bill are uh I'm sure there are other
co-founders but you were two co-founders
were mines mines for those aren't
familiar is a social media platform you
can use it's actually got tons of uh
functionality it's great and we went to
the social media Summit why because the
Trump Administration knew this was a
problem I thought it was going to be an
actual conversation where I'd be able to
go in and see some people in the
administration or in government and say
here's what I think the issue is now I
actually said I was asked and
interviewed what are you going there for
and I said I think conservatives too
often think they're the only ones being
censored and there are many progressives
who are anti-establishment or anti-war
who are getting censored too that's why
it's not about just conservatives it's
about allowing people the right to speak
before it's too late instead Donald
Trump put on what I would call a VIP
Trump rally now mind you Donald Trump is
hilarious it really is it was a stand-up
routine he was it was self-deprecating
humor he was talking it was like it was
almost like Jon Stewart level a kind of
comedy and I was impressed and I'm like
well we're not getting getting anything
done today someone asks a question they
so they're doing Q a and then and then
someone said will you join to Trump
directly will you join any other you
know social media platform and Trump
goes which one which one
and that was it he never did he has no
idea what he was doing he doesn't
understand technology he never talked
about fusion power he never talked about
he would say we need to ban section 230
like he's a more he's not a [ __ ] he was
ignorant of Technology unfortunately I
mean he used Twitter as a bully he used
Twitter as a way to speak to the people
directly away from the mainstream media
so you can't say he was totally ignorant
of it he knew the game he played the
game very well he played up very poorly
because he was bad for himself I mean he
just destroyed his legacy but then when
it came to standing up for the people
that supported him he he let's be honest
here he didn't do anything for me and it
wasn't only just taxes it was also the
Second Amendment he did nothing in favor
of the Second Amendment when he had the
house he had the Senate he could have
passed legislation that could have
helped the Second Amendment didn't do
any of that hold on that's the that's
that's the establishment Republican
party the first two years Trump was in
office it was
um Paul Ryan the Republicans who are in
power are like here's the way I describe
it when Trump and Bernie LED their a
Siege on the establishment Tower Bernie
eventually got bought out and joined the
ranks thinking that was the best way in
Trump was just banging on the door
screaming once he got in the established
Republicans were like well we normally
don't have to work all of a sudden now
we got this guy yelling at us claiming
he's in charge and now we have to do
work I retire I quit I'm out I'm not
running for reelection and they were
just bowing out like crazy and then the
Democrats came in and won controlled the
house
so the Republicans in 2016-17 and 18 or
I should say 2017 and 18. to the end of
2018. they didn't want to do anything
and they didn't do anything so Trump
didn't have them in his corner now that
Trump is out and it's back to Biden The
Establishment is back in control they're
going to lock the doors Bernie's gonna
get the boot it's it's not going to have
another progressives and the left
populist thought was going to happen
censorship is going to get extreme to
the point where well they're already
Banning progressives tons of progressive
YouTube channels got nuked recently and
I'm sitting here going listen I'm not
going to rag on these people I'm not
going to insult them I'm not going to
mock them and say told you so I'm going
to say welcome to the fight now can we
please get a serious conversation about
why you need to be allowed to speak
hopefully now that they're listening we
can have some kind of I think majority
that opposes where will that
conversation happen when when people are
being censored for even you can't go to
the bar and you can't have events yeah
you know here so depressing you can kind
of have a conversation on YouTube as
long as you don't insult people kind of
I mean we uh YouTube's YouTube is pretty
bad in a lot of ways but we're talking
little bit before the show it's not as
bad as a lot of people think it is yeah
it's better than most you know yeah like
uh YouTube takes intent into question
when it comes to hate speech seriously
yeah and Twitter doesn't Instagram
doesn't none of those do I think there
are people that have been on off of
everything but YouTube like the people
that still have their YouTube better ban
off everything else I was thinking maybe
the problem with free speech and forcing
free speech on these social networks is
you want to allow the private networks
to maintain control of their terms of
service because it becomes kind of
authoritarian when you tell them how to
they keep changing their their terms of
services I signed a term and services
with the social media companies and they
keep changing it sure that's not fair
especially with individuals that put
their whole livelihoods their whole
business their whole salary on social
media and then they just change the
change the rules Midway and they'll
specify using the service you would you
would accept it automatically and plus
the terms will be like 45 pages long
which is like almost impossible for a
human to go through why don't we just I
don't know maybe create something new or
treat treat some some of these social
networks like a utility in the sense
that there's no banning at all if
someone goes out the middle of the
street and screams a death threat at
somebody else yeah the cops will arrest
you for that you can't do that you can't
go around screaming I'm gonna you know
do this to you or do that to you it's
illegal so what if there was just a
platform that was I I that functioned
very similar similarly to if you were
walking around outside you can buy ad
space on it it's the certain ad space on
the site is controlled by individuals
who've bought the rights to run ads on
it or whatever and if listen here's the
way I put it a lot is the advertisers
freak out because they're like I don't
want to run ads on Twitter because
people on Twitter say mean words and I'm
like you put up a billboard in like La
for instance what's going to stop some
crazy racist guy from standing in front
of your billboard screaming and then
someone taking a picture and putting it
online right you can't you can't escape
that so maybe
we need and honestly I think it's
probably uh it's it's kind of I don't
know maybe a mootin point of this as of
now because we we've said it so many
times we need a social media platform
that is a utility it doesn't have to be
Twitter
and you know what Trump could have done
it that's the big thing yeah Trump could
have got on parlor gab or mines he could
have even made his own broadcast
platform where you go to like you know
Trump's the wardoftrump.com and it gave
you his personal Twitter feed he could
have even done that and then people
would have followed Trump could have
launched his own network he could have
done everything and he did nothing man
even if he would have joined just one of
them whether it be gab mines one of
these other ones it would send such a
massive wave of people to join just
because to be made aware of it you know
and it's like he never did it it's was
messed up would you suggest using the
government to make one then like a
socialist type of utility I don't think
that's socialist socialism is owning the
means of production yeah publicly owned
with a Bill of Rights the Bill of Rights
guarantee so the reason I like the idea
of a public utility social platform is
because we have the first amendment that
means you can go on there and you can
say dumb opinions whether you're left
right whatever and unless and you can
there is speech that is illegal and I
think for the most part there are a lot
of free speeches Free Speech absolutists
who will say even inciting or
threatening is just words they don't
hurt anybody most people right now
accept directing someone instructing
them in like telling them to do it or
actually doing it themselves like
threatening you can't do that that's
illegal right so if like I said if you
were walking around you know New York
City screaming I'm gonna I'm gonna do X
to you I'm gonna do whatever to you ah
the cops would come and be like right
this way buddy that's illegal that's
that's a threat New York they might just
Scuttle you along and say get out of
here because they don't want to deal
with it in Chicago probably take it more
seriously in Chicago if you threaten
someone like yell it they they very well
may arrest you because that's assault
according to Chicago Law
we could just do that you got you got a
problem with some you don't like their
opinions block bye-bye now I never see
you again the government could take
mine's code and start it just spin one
up they could easily do that publicize
the hell out of it buying this so much
influence he could just publish they
don't want to and make it all about law
listen listen the big corporations have
all the power and say on there too
because that's that's the one of the
reasons why the government's not doing
anything sitting on their butts as
people are losing their rights to free
speech right now and again you don't
need Big Daddy Tech deciding what you
can and cannot hear leave it to the law
we we have libel laws right we have laws
against threatening other individuals
leave it to the law we don't need tech
oligarchs unaccountable people deciding
yes or no you can and cannot say this
what do you mean if we that the big text
would have control on that if because
again when you look at the government
right the government has been
essentially bought and sold by the
special interest by the billionaire
class by the multinational industrial uh
Industries out there that of course do
the bidding for them if you think the US
government represents you you you're
fooling yourself they don't they
represent the people that they're
friends with that are super elitist that
are super rich that cash their pockets
with money those are the people they
serve so if the government creates
something who you think is going to get
the most prominent Voice or more control
over everything it's going to be them
obviously who would we who what what
organization would we use to enforce
like free speech laws then if not the
government it's called Free Speech you
don't need to enforce Free Speech you'd
uh again if you have local jurisdictions
like in Chicago like in New York they
usually handle the situation themselves
so if you have a jurisdiction and if you
have someone that slandered you or
liable you deal it through that system
that's that's just a simple way of doing
it decentralization not centralization
is the answer I'd like to show you guys
a study just in response to what Luke
was saying from 2014 I will also stress
there are rebuttals to this that are
more modern but this is from the BBC 24
April 2014 study US is an oligarchy he
not a democracy and the BBC reports the
U.S is dominated by a rich and Powerful
Elite so concludes a recent study by
Princeton University Professor Martin
gillens and Northwestern University
Professor Benjamin page this is not news
you say perhaps the two professors have
conducted exhaustive research to try and
present data-driven support for this
conclusion here's how they explain it
multivariate analysis indicates that
economic Elites and organized groups
representing business interests have
substantial independent impacts on U.S
government policy while average citizens
and mass-based interest groups have
little or no independent influence in
English the wealthy few move policy
while the average American has little
power they're going to say that they
drew this conclusion by uh reviewing
answers to 1779 survey questions asked
between 1981 and 2002 on Public public
policy issues they say quote a proposed
policy change with low support among
economically Elite Americans one out of
five in favor is adopted only about 18
of the time they write while a proposed
change with high support four out of
five is adopted about 45 percent of the
time on the other hand when a majority
of citizens disagrees with economic
Elites and or with organized interests
they generally lose moreover because of
the strong status quo bias built into
the US political system even when fairly
large majorities of American of
Americans favor policy change they
generally do not get it they conclude
Americans do enjoy many features Central
to democratic governance such as regular
elections freedom of speech well at the
time I suppose an association and a
freelance region Association and a
widespread if still can contested
franchise we believe that if policy
making is dominated by powerful business
organizations and a small number of
affluent Americans then America's claim
to being a democracy Democratic Society
are seriously threatened and I'll just
stress this study made it very obvious
what was going to happen next they don't
want large powerful majorities forming
it's hard to defeat now the study
mentioned that if a large majority says
we want this policy they still tend to
lose but that still means the powerful
Elites have to fight against these ideas
Occupy Wall Street was very popular they
found a way to fracture using identity
politics well take away free speech you
don't got to deal with it ever again so
they're monopolizing the platforms with
which we communicate while the
governments have stopped us from
communicating in person
how do we go I don't if if we don't use
the government to enforce free speech on
the internet who else will
you mean we should the government should
yeah that's what I'm talking about
making a gun but the problem I I kind of
want to delve into Luke's Point earlier
about decentralizing it and but they
won't because they helped create these
monopolies that they're tied into in
such ways that they they will never
uncouple let me let me let me just
repeat the point of this study Ian to
read to you is that the government does
what their lobbyist corporate interests
tell them to do that's always been the
case with the U.S right and so why would
they do anything different Twitter is
going to say hey whoa what are you doing
there oh I'm sorry I mean I don't want
to just say I guess the US government
was a militaristic corrupt system from
the beginning you know it wasn't a
genocidal yeah it was it was a genocidal
military takeover of the Native American
population that's and they very
accomplished they made a they made a
government that was ruled by the
powerful Elite these landowners and they
gave very little power to the masses bro
you're you're con you're con you're
taking hundreds of years of colonial
history and condensing it into like 20.
they when they made the the government
it was like we pick who the Senators are
the first first the when the United
States was that's what I'm talking about
yeah yeah it was it was actually a mix
it was modeled very similarly off of the
UK where you have the people's
representation and then you have the
better men yeah the Senators and the
Republicans who are appointed but that
actually was a better system you know
why because you would vote for your
local Representatives you'd vote at the
state level and then they would appoint
federal representatives to go to
Senators not Congress people so now
because we shifted senatorial elections
to the to the public people don't care
about voting locally anymore so now
their states are you know in disrepair
and you know what's crazy is there's a
there's this push now from uh some Trump
supporters apparently there's like
Precinct level Republican positions that
are half empty across the country that
have powerful control over how the
political how the GOP nominates people
allocates resources and they're missing
because people aren't running they don't
know there's huge gaps in how the how
the GOP is supposed to be running so
because of that because people have
ignored local politics it's created
vulnerabilities that can now be
exploited by Trump supporters you need
to pay attention to your local politics
most people don't even know who who
their state senators are who their state
reps are who their Congress person even
is I feel like it's changed a bit though
with the pandemic in 2020. I even I've
been way more aware of local politics
than ever just because of the pandemic
and the lockdowns and you start seeing
like oh Florida is back to real life and
I'm not I can't even leave my house wow
and then it all comes down to local
politics yep whether or not your state
is going to say yes or no apparently
Florida is you know they've been saying
do your thing and then we've seen the
collective outrage from the media on the
left so you mentioned making a utility
an internet website that was utility
social network you mentioned
decentralizing it and you've mentioned
local politics so if we made like a an
internet social network that was
decentralized and like La had its own
the only problem is that wouldn't work
to me because when you use social
networking you don't want to just only
talk to people in your city you want
like Global connectivity who oversees it
well there's there's several Solutions
and maybe
there have there have been attempts to
pass these laws to stop censorship at
the state level I think that's the key I
think you know Florida might actually
pull this off because DeSantis recently
talked about you know they're proposing
this bill that would find big tech
companies for violating violating a set
of rules
there you go don't we don't need to rely
on Congress or or the Senate just have
your state do it because they can do it
very easily if if you're in Arizona or
Michigan or Wisconsin or Pennsylvania
and you've got a republican control
legislature what's to stop them from
passing this law make them do it call
them up tell them what you want tell
them what you're willing to vote for do
that phone campaign and if they don't
listen vote for somebody else I love
DeSantis I hope he runs for president
seriously he might I mean he's really
standing up what's he doing always open
to Florida he's opened up Florida and I
was there over Christmas break it was in
Miami and it was just it was amazing it
was real life again you know living in
La it's like it's not but I guess La is
real life too this lockdown is real life
yeah but Newsom will shut off your water
or oh but they're gonna recall that guy
huh like they gotta I think they just
got enough signatures and I'm like oh my
God
goodbye I signed months ago yeah what
does that mean is he out of office
officially now or something no
um I think there's a certain amount of
signatures that needs to be had and then
we can vote on it as a state so I don't
I don't know if there's a step before
that or what but I think we can vote on
it soon it's like a ballot initiative
just like they did with marijuana and
other laws it's decided by popular vote
rather than just local government that's
how Switzerland is also run well let's
uh let's dive into the story actually
and see what's going on with uh with
your awful State of California lawyer I
hate California sorry I lived there it's
beautiful but it's so ugly right it's
ugly I'm like I don't know like a
personality level yeah the state had a
lot of plastic surgery yes yes that's
unfortunate man I mean we got this from
we have to start from 538. California's
Gavin Newsom will likely face a recall
election but he'll probably survive it
who wrote that 538 sounds like
propaganda well I know I was gonna say
that because 538 failed miserably in the
2020 election and the 2016 election and
they were so mad about it what was that
one well all the polls were historically
off by like what was it what was the
average like seven points it was worse
in 2020 than it was in 2016. my favorite
thing about the polls was the New York
Times had safe Democrat lean Democrat
toss-up lean Republican safe Republican
and the whole thing skewed red ski
Republican so the lean Democrat all went
Republican and then the safe Democrat
actually some seats flipped Republican
that's why they were able to regain a
lot of the house they were so wrong so
now it is true let me let me read a
little bit of the story just give you
guys context they say
California governor Gavin Newsom has
been in office for just two years but
there have already been five failed
attempts to force a Statewide recall
election on whether to remove him from
office that itself is unusual California
has some of the most permissive recall
requirements in the country but what is
you what is unusual is that the sixth
attempt which is currently underway
appears to be gaining some serious
traction if it makes the ballot the
election would be just the fourth
gubernatorial recall election in all of
American history and two of the previous
three governors to face recalls ended up
going down in defeat including
California's in 2003 when in the midst
of a Statewide fiscal crisis 55 percent
of Voters opted to recall Democrat Gray
Davis an elected Republican Arnold
Schwarzenegger in the in his place that
seems like a bad Omen for Newsome until
you consider for special circumstances
of this recall and the political
evolution of California well I'm not
interested in their overall assessment
the point is it's everyone else has lost
and it's over what 1.5 million
signatures now to get rid of Newsome
yeah so he could be gone I mean just
what it shows is how angry people are I
mean
I don't think you can look at what's
happening in California which is we are
the most locked down Place La
specifically is the most lockdown and
yet we're the worst of the cases there
was a story that the air that people in
La were breathing was like
um polluted with uh from the what's it
called when they burn people the
crematorium crematoriums yeah really
that the air was so polluted because
people were dying at such a frequent
rate and but what's so crazy is that you
know obviously there is a growing
movement of people who are angry about
the leadership in California but there
are still so many people there that
think it's like
he's doing a great job simply because
he's Democrat and they look at Florida
and they look at DeSantis and they're
like oh my God I can't believe they're
fully open that's so messed up and it's
like but they're not worse off than us
so what is the logic at this point if
you support
lockdowns and the way that they've been
imposed I think there's something
seriously wrong with you it's a cult it
really is when they when they complain
about Trump supporters and they're like
you know I see these posts on Facebook
all the time they're like Trump
supporters you're in a cult I'm like you
know okay I I know the people they're
referring to they're referring to the Q
people who believe this crazy nonsense I
understand why they're saying that my
response to them is usually like I hear
you I hear you do you think you're in a
cult you don't have you'll have you have
you considered maybe y'all are crazy the
right and these and these these really
zealous Trump supporters don't have
cultural power in the cultural
institutions and they had very limited
political power with Trump as president
Trump was struggling in a lot of ways to
do a lot of things he was able to pull
off a lot don't get me wrong right now
the Democrats control every cultural
institution and every branch of
government well except for the Supreme
Court but we'll see what happens they're
fairly pro-establishment we'll see how
they end up ruling and look where we're
at everyone's still begging for scraps
from the government after almost a year
in a pandemic or people can't afford
food rent to survive and yet for some
reason some people still just like are
so much more comfortable with Democratic
Leadership and they don't get it it's a
cult you know so I'm not saying
everybody would have voted for our
Democrats I call that's ridiculous every
Trump supporter wasn't some zealous
conspiracy conspiracy theorist it's just
that in the cultural institutions you
have substantially more cult-like
Democrat people who just would
absolutely watch the whole country burn
down if it meant they were owning the
cons you have a similar element among
right Wingers for sure but they don't
have any power they're not that's what
that's why I've never really cared to be
like oh so that you know that that queue
guy you know he said something dumb on
Twitter I don't care he doesn't control
the entirety of the party he doesn't
control Hollywood or TV shows or digital
marketing and he's not controlling a
branch of government now it's it's all
Democrats it's the liberal economic
order they started at the British and
the Americans started it after World War
II to basically control the world with
military so there's like this military
you know propaganda effort that's
controlled by this liberal force that
could be economic I don't think liberal
makes them make sense because actually
the specific term is liberal economic
orders right I I I know but I mean like
they call themselves Liberal Republicans
and Democrats are doing the same thing
you know the the Republican Party the
Democratic party are working towards the
same goal I think the Republicans are
just like a caricature of a villain
where they do literally nothing but
obstruct in certain ways to make
Democrats angry and never actually fight
for causes that the people on the right
actually want right so when Trump came
around and said I'm gonna fight for you
they're like finally somebody and then
Trump did some things and ultimately
didn't get a lot through because he was
obstructed at every turn even his own
administration his own Administration
apparently the reason Trump didn't get
on parlor or gab was because of Jared
Kushner who was like don't do it don't
go on don't don't do it okay well now
he's gone now he can't say anything
we've got in this country
Democrats in States like California and
places like New York pushing policies
and winning elections while people
suffer and beg for scraps like you were
mentioning and and the reason why I say
it's a cult is because no matter what
happens they will not let it go I had a
friend
sent them the Time Magazine you see the
Time magazine article about the shadow
campaign Blair yeah
um like how much more explicit could
they make it right when they said a
shadow campaign a conspiracy in the
background by an elite cabal of powerful
individuals started in Fall of 2019 mind
you which means they were doing it to
Bernie Sanders to ensure the proper
outcome and my friend was like oh but
they were just fortifying the election
and I said you realize the Democratic
primary didn't conclude until 2020 which
means they were doing it to Bernie
Sanders and then all of a sudden they
were like yeah I'm like yeah did you
notice they weren't it wasn't about
Trump trump was a part of it it's about
the people getting an actual candidate
who represented them unfortunately
Bernie sold out He Wants To Be A
Millionaire you know that's why I feel
so disaffected between the left versus
right thing now at this point it's if
you don't
at some point if you don't start seeing
that it's the elites versus the the
people then I don't really know what's
wrong with you especially the last year
the last year has revealed so much about
just the way the system works the ways
in which it's broken the ways in which
it doesn't just not serve the people but
it actively crushes the people that you
have so many people that still vote for
that same system and what's really scary
is that now that Biden's in power
we talked about this earlier now it's
back to sort of the Obama era of like
just complete um
like not even caring about politics at
all what's the right word like blind
ignorance and obedience combined like
compliance but it's but it's not even
devotion it's because they don't they
don't actually like Biden good point no
one likes but it's not even compliance
it's like it's like subservience
complacency complacency hold on but it's
like a willful disregard of information
yes and a and willful ignorance to allow
Biden to do whatever he wants and turn
away and not pay attention anymore I
think the word is witness a blind
witness because he's a Democrat so
nothing he does is going to be bad and
everything anyone who's Republican does
is bad I know you know you know what I
loved about Obama was when uh when when
he ran and you know anti-war and all
that stuff and I voted for him I was all
excited and then I think it was January
23rd of 2009 I could be getting the data
day wrong like only a few days after
inauguration he ordered a drone strike
on a village of Women and Children
Killing civilians and I was just like I
felt like my heart sink like
he he was supposed to say no he was
supposed to know and then I would go to
my friends and all of a sudden all these
anti-war activists were just all of a
sudden like I don't know I know what
you're talking about I don't care
um we're gonna go get pizza at the bar
and just have a drink it's the same
thing now the war drums are starting to
beat up again with Biden and it's like
where is everyone that cares no one okay
no one I guess no one it's like it's
like the dominoes are falling down yeah
and we're watching it happen and we
can't do anything to stop it it's like
the whole the whole thing's gone well
even if people did rise up or or did
voice their disgust you wouldn't know
about it because your algorithm is
curated your timeline is carefully
selected to make sure that you see and
have a perception that these Elite
billionaires want you to see and Blair
you made a very good point it's
something that I've been screaming about
for years now endlessly I've been
ridiculed and attacked for it but it's
not left versus right it's you versus
the secret Club of billionaires and
that's exactly what's happening right
now and these billionaires they're
getting their way they're getting their
their power they're getting their money
more than they ever did before because
of these lockdowns and then we have
individuals like Bill Gates that by the
way just recently became the largest
Farmland owner in all of the United
States seriously lecturing us about how
we need to lock down more congratulating
China about doing us a great job but
also just as of today became the biggest
shareholder in the Canadian national
railroad what a major yes a major
railroad company that doesn't doesn't
just provide transportation services for
all of Canada but also along the
Mississippi from the north to the south
of the United States and literally he's
on his way from almost controlling the
entire food supply chain from Farm to
Table and Bill Gates is buying up more
assets buying up more companies buying
up more land than ever before who would
have thought Bill Gates would be The
Reincarnation of Alexander the Great
anchoring conquering large swaths of
territory around the world
the largest shareholder of the Canadian
national railroad could you could you
imagine sorry just like I'm thinking
about the the legends of like Genghis
Khan and Alexander the Great riding in
on Horseback and conquering land and now
we have this great warlord conqueror and
it's Bill Gates saying well I recently
purchased in a sweater vest right to add
insults to injury yeah I mean this man
was was described as a ruthless
businessman who changed his ways was
going to donate all of his money to
charity uh almost more than doubled his
money by the way uh but but he's the one
that that all the mainstream media guys
are are going for for the expert advice
about what to do next he also pushed the
goal post because a couple months ago he
said that these lockdowns as kovitz
going to be be with us until 2021 he
changed his stance now he's saying 2022
and of course who benefits off of these
lockdowns billionaires like him you know
what gets me is that like I feel like
the left is always talking about class
Consciousness and it's like I'm down to
top that conversation but it's like so
so you all support these lockdowns and
you don't see how the rich is getting
richer you're getting poorer I just saw
an article the top hundred billionaires
most wealthy their wealth has increased
by 40 percent since absolutely you know
what's funny is there's we we did
mention this before but I love this
moment where Tucker Carlson was doing
his handoff with Sean Hannity and Tucker
was talking about how these massive
corporations value is skyrocketing about
this lockdown basically saying how it's
the largest transfer of wealth from the
working class to the wealthy in in the
history of humanity and then when he's
doing the handoff Hannity goes if a
business provides a service and makes
money well then good for them they're
allowed to do it and Tucker's response
was the Tucker face where he's like
looking like huh yeah the labrador like
what I love that interaction yeah how is
it that Tucker Carlson had this
Evolution on on populism and you know
the elites versus the people
and and it's just it's basically him the
the rest of cable TV and everybody are
still very much pro-established well
that's why they're trying to counsel him
so much right and usually the stuff that
he talks about is is very important he
talks about I don't always agree with
him but he does it from an honest
perspective he does it from an honest
way and he points out how it's not
private Enterprise these these are not
businesses engaging in the free market
these are quasi-station extensions of
the government working with government
hand in hand pushing and and making sure
the game is rigged against everyone else
so they get their way and they've been
getting their way Non-Stop and it's so
sad how no one thinks to take it that
far in their mind when they're looking
around at them and they're seeing all of
their fellow citizens living like dogs
on their on their knees I will swore and
it's so frustrating how they use these
tools of pitting us against each other
and so before anyone would start to
think about how maybe all of this is a
ploy to crush the poor and make the rich
richer they'll look at someone with the
mass lightly beneath their nose in a
grocery store and have a psychotic
meltdown and convince themselves that
that one individual who's not wearing
the mask perfectly to how they think it
should go is the reason why we're in
this mask I see it all the time it's a
cult and they sell they sell this so
that you know this is this is the space
helmet that I bought and you know like I
want to be I I don't like being mean to
people like the guy who made this seems
like a nice guy is a really interesting
idea but I swear to God if if you're
going to be wearing the space helmet
because of this strange cult-like
Behavior around masks we've got we got
problems man there it you know what I am
partly grateful to everything that's
happened over the past year I suppose in
at least one way it's not always bad
it's kind of it's almost like you know
when they're doing these medical
procedures to like up for cancer they'll
inject your bloodstream with dye or like
they'll make you drink it right is that
what they do
sounds right then they can like take the
scanning machine whatever it is and see
all your veins light up yeah they
basically did that with dumb people
so now when you see people walking
around with space helmets and like four
masks you're like okay this person
doesn't think critically right they
don't do any investigation thank you I
understand wearing a mask the logic is
very very simple so I have no problem
wearing it I do think it's absurd when
they're like wear a mask in your own
home I'm like no what where I'm asking
your own home and between bites it's
like okay you gotta chill there or like
in California they were telling you
literally take a bite put your mask back
on when you're in the right and Kevin
newsom's not doing a mask at all
by the way I was on a plane I've had two
connecting flights here and both of
those planes the over the flight
attendant speaker they're saying even
when you're chewing you have to put it
up when you chew and then swallow take
it off take a bite shoe with the with it
on it's crazy this is of course as the
CDC just ruled recently that two masks
are recommended uh after fauci couple
days ago said there's no evidence
supporting that now fauci again
flip-flops saying yes actually now wear
two masks when in the beginning he said
don't wear any any masks because they're
all I get total constant flip-flopping
and you call them up you call these
these these these lying you have an
absolutely friendly show I know yeah do
you want a second one we have two of
them you put two of them it looks like
the thing you take a crap in at the
hospital yeah
so the funny thing about is like what if
you you're wearing this you sneeze yeah
that's what everyone says you just spray
the whole plastic
I've ever seen a person sneeze in their
mask I've seen it a couple times you're
so gross do you see Joe Biden take his
mask off to cough in his hand and then
put the mask back on yeah yeah he did it
it's great hilarious yeah but no we're
actually here right now we have this
from NPR CDC says double masking offers
more protection against the coronavirus
uh what what is what is wrong with that
obviously but what how what percent six
percent more it is yeah it's like six
percent then what what it's diminishing
returns at what point are you gonna say
enough because the Third Mask will give
you another point seven percent increase
apparently and I don't know if this is
true but I was reading uh uh I was
reading a an article about this and they
said the study found or a study found
that after like seven masks it starts
becoming detrimental seven yeah yeah
seven like can we stop pretending like
we can breathe in the mass that's my
whole thing it's like why is everyone
lying because if I walk even more than
three feet in a mass I'm
hyperventilating I do have asthma as
well I know everyone gets so mad when
you say that but like I I can't breathe
well doesn't that mean you're exempting
you know how to wear it I don't think so
so I don't think asthma is an exemption
but I mean I don't look I don't wanna
paint a wrong impression of me I will
wear a mask especially in a public
business because at the end of the day I
just won't go in the business if I don't
want to wear a mask I'd become I comply
with that kind of stuff well it gets a
different level when it's like you're
outside walking your dog and you post a
Snapchat and all the replies are like
why aren't you wearing it um curse word
math like it's like you're killing
Grandma it's like no one's near me I'm
with my dog and I remember at the start
of the pandemic I had this experience I
tweeted about it where a cop literally
approached me to tell me to put a mask
on and he broke the six feet and he
didn't have a masma that's why I'm I'm
going to unironically wear this you
might as well no here's what I'm going
to do the reason I bought I bought these
I bought two of them I bought them for a
reason uh they're silly and they're
hilarious they're great but also it
gives me the moral authority to shame
everyone around me right you have a
super mask and what's funny is they're
not going to know what I'm saying
because you can barely talk in these
things but I also purposefully muffle my
voice so I'm looking at him going run
run run
and they're gonna be back I don't know
why you're yelling at me and then I'll
take off and go you're only wearing a
cloth mask you're killing Grandma buy
your plastic space helmet now otherwise
you you evil fascist that's what they
all sound like to me anyway it's just
muffled like like the teacher from
Charlie Brown yeah
um in L.A there's this area where I go
hiking all the time called Runyan Canyon
yeah I love it and it's outdoors no one
has to get anywhere near you you're
literally on a mountain okay and the
city has what I call Green Jackets which
is guys in Green Jackets at the entrance
that will yell at you to put a mask on
and I just yeah I call them green
jackets I just walk past them they'll
literally yell stuff and I'll just walk
past maybe I'll wait like I just don't
care it's like I'm not gonna wear one
outside when I'm exercising and there's
already dust coming up from it's like no
I was on uh I was in a forest
a few months ago literally in the forest
okay
and I saw it it's a path there's like a
path right so people are riding bikes
people wearing masks and I'm like dude
right you not not only are nowhere near
any humans you are so far from humans
you risk dying if you make a wrong turn
I think you're okay to not wear it look
I understand stores
I understand you go to a business but
I'll tell you if you're in the woods I
think you're okay my favorite what I
personally saw in New Hampshire was
someone riding a motorcycle without a
helmet but with a mask and when you have
individuals like that that's when I knew
that's uh seeing that I'm like we're
screwed but but the first realization
with this whole coronavirus when I knew
we were screwed was when the government
was telling everyone don't wear a mask
it's fine don't get them and then when
they told everyone no no well actually
wear a mask and there wasn't any
repercussions there wasn't any kind of
backlash I knew we were in trouble so so
this is this is the important thing here
the government could lie to you as as
much as they want but if you lie to the
government in the United Kingdom they
just put in new security laws that you
will face 10 years in jail if you lie to
the government about your whereabouts a
ten thousand dollar fine for leaving
your quarantine and if you're entering
the United Kingdom you now have to buy a
quarantine package that is two thousand
four hundred dollars which includes a 10
10-day hotel stay and covid tests so you
have to pay this out of pocket if you
want to visit at the United Kingdom you
know honestly wow I will say I will say
one thing double masking the way they
describe it makes sense for one simple
reason
if you're gonna wear a mask and I do
like we went we go to the restaurant we
just went we just went out we go
shopping you wear a mask when you go in
and I understand the point you know
people don't want to get sick
those things get really nasty people
don't wash their masks true so they're
they're wearing them all day every day
for months and it's becoming grimy and
infested they're saying we're a
disposable math mask and then put your
other mask over it
I wonder if the real issue is they're
like dude these people are walking
around with fungus Rags on their faces
right maybe that we should tell them to
put a disposable underneath it because
now they do and it's like if you're not
gonna wear your mask that I kind of get
yeah I've even gone to the point where
sometimes it's like if I have to go
somewhere I'll just throw one on and
like it's dirty and I know it's dirty
and I take the L and it's disgusting
their masks on the ground it really is
bad for you I was wearing dirty bandages
I did something really bad one time oh
no I had to go into a Target and it was
an emergency like I had to go on the
target okay I was in the parking garage
I dropped my mask on the ground in the
parking garage oh no put it on my face
and then I tasted the ground
it was disgusting I think I think uh I
think we we got it I think we got to
mandate these these Dome helmets yes
well this is the thing The Masks work so
well why haven't they worked no I
disagree with that one though I disagree
yeah because uh I've heard people say it
if the masks work so well why aren't
they working well we have no metric by
which ticket well we saw we saw some we
saw some statistics and we see where
there's mask mandates implemented when
they're where they're not implemented
and we saw ever since the beginning of
the Mask mandates a lot of the counties
and districts that did implement the
mandates their cases their numbers went
up a lot of places like Florida this is
the comparative that happened because
NBC News launched an attack on a grow
grocery store in Florida and then and
then it was a vicious attack they were
like look at these grandmas they're not
wearing any masks they're in the
supermarket they're horrible human
beings a whole huge segment on on The
Today Show shaming them and then someone
I forgot his name he works for the for
for an independent media organization
and and he he put out a sign saying look
at the number of cases here in this
particular County in Florida compared to
of course Los Angeles uh in the Los
Angeles I forgot which one uh but also
similar populations and then he it was
like look at the numbers mask mandate
here no mask mandate here the the uh the
county in California huge spikes Florida
leveled out this is now again could be
could be uh
it's a different place yes it's not
exact but but there might be it might be
worth investigating that's all I'm
saying it was a really high compliance
statistics with Matthew aren't like most
people in general majority of people are
wearing masks you'd have to have a group
of like a hundred people no not wear
masks and another group of 100 wear
masks in the exact same place going to
the exact same businesses and then track
it to see if there's a we haven't done
that and you got to know what they had
before they got selected right right
were they exposed food they're eating
exercise all that stuff's got to be
controlled for so New York La Florida
all very different places but we have to
understand I think it's fair to be
critical don't get me wrong we should be
critical because there is some data
actually showing that masks actually do
help with influenzas especially in Asian
countries especially with how they've
been utilized and used but this is not
the flu this is something else this is
something where we had a 117 year old
nun one of the oldest people in the
world have this not even though she had
it while other people are getting
absolutely devastated by this there's
fingers falling off yeah so I'm like
what yeah yeah there's a there's a a
story that came out a woman's fingers
fell off right we don't know it was uh
it was uh the the so some people
remember that basketball player who
collapsed on the court
he's like he recovered from coven then
one day he was playing and then he just
fell down it does impact people like
that this is the thing affects their
circulation I've talked to a lot of
doctors and nurses all a lot of them
don't know what's going on they're so
confused that they're so perplexed I
mean I see you not in your head there
Lydia because you're in this profession
we don't know what's going on here so so
implementing these these hard rules and
stopping any discourse from happening is
hurting us friends that died of cancer
officially of cancer but what happened
was they got diagnosed they went into
the hospital started getting these these
crazy chemical things to try and kill
stuff we're gonna kill it we're gonna
find it and kill it and kill a bunch of
other stuff in your body while we do it
collateral damage and their bodies
started getting devastated and then they
died
they died from cancer they died from
chemo and they call it cancer death yes
but it's not a secret that when people
get cancer they're on the track to die
and chemo can actually kill them it
could also say that's the theory but
these people get the chemo oh and it's
so hard on the body that it ends up they
end up dying way and so but they call it
a cancer death so it's a similar thing
with covet yeah people's fingers are
falling off but that doesn't mean that
covet made their fingers fall off it but
in this story that's literally the story
that's how the story was written and you
know yeah but I like let's go into the
story then I'd love to hear okay come on
that's crazy no no I'm serious actually
no it's crazy fingers come on yeah yeah
because you know what coveted toes is
when people get bad circulation from
covid then the extremities your fingers
and your toes start but are they obese I
think this person was elderly actually
yeah the point is we've not not
everybody's affected the same way and it
has been I think to Luke's point about
people being scared or confused it's new
we we've not experienced and it seems to
be very serious and people are kind of
freaked out about it that's true so I'm
I say this the masks to me makes total
sense now when they say two masks I'm
like it's like a six percent increase
according to these studies
look man wearing a mask at a store makes
sense in public places but can finding
people to their homes is clearly the
data shown that doesn't work because
people then spread it to their family
members so letting people go outside so
this is one of the reasons why they're
starting to reopen is like even in
California they realized well that maybe
Newsome panicking because they're going
to recall him but they realized when
people go outside these businesses can
enforce social distancing and mask
wearing when people are going inside
they'll go out and interact publicly at
stores or Walmart and then bring it back
and infect their whole families yes and
also it's like you're making laws and
and mandates that go against
fundamental aspects of human nature like
humans need Community they need to be
around each other they need God forbid
Sunshine every once in a while so what
you're doing is you're creating an
underground and I'll I'll talk about
this maybe people don't know this in La
there is such a huge underground party
scene right now especially in the LGBT
community
um warehouses in La just full of people
partying these are the same people that
are online you know yeah that are super
lived out about covid and super anal
about it
um but that's what's happening is the
government is the lockouts are so harsh
that it's causing the opposite effect so
instead of going to an outdoor
restaurant where the tables are six feet
and you wear a mask when you walk to
your table whatever people are like okay
I can't even do that but I need to be
around people they end up going to a
party you know what's funny is every
high school party is always is illegal
right every teenager under the age of 21
partying and getting drunk they know
what happens when the cops show up
they're like cheese it and everyone's
running random directions and like the
cops are coming in you're like oh no no
out the back door so now all they're
doing is the same thing it's like they
so now they're 24 and they're doing it
but they're accustomed to this I mean I
don't know about most of you listening
but when I was a teenager we would show
up to some random house party you're in
the kitchen you got a 40 a king cobra or
whatever cost you a buck and then all of
a sudden you hear like someone runs in
like dude cops are pulling up and then
everyone runs you're hopping the fence
to get out and yeah because you're not
you can't be drinking and then like the
person who owns it the cops yell at them
they'll get a ticket or something so now
what's happening we've I've heard
stories I was in New Jersey these women
were having a warehouse party and they
were serving food and gambling so now
it's like now not only are they having
this Close Quarters there's no food
sanitation there's no regulation and
they're gambling along with it because
prohibition doesn't work it just doesn't
work lockdowns don't work it's basically
prohibition of life it's like don't live
your life they found covet in ice cream
in China I don't know if you heard about
it allegedly we also have to understand
a lot of the data that we're getting
from these quote experts and medical
professionals flip-flops every week so
we don't know if they're telling the
truth or not because they've send out so
many mixed messages they send out things
saying no Airborne transmission now
there is Airborne transmission we don't
know what's going on here and the
medical community is left stunned and
again as you said prohibition never
works and it never has worked nothing
the government tries to stop and there
have even been some scientific studies
showing that if you make people coalesce
only in Walmart only in Target that
that's going to actually spread the
virus more if people are only told to go
to one place place and they only go to
that one place yes so so there's there's
data suggesting that again a lot of
uncertainties we don't know what's going
on I'll tell you my uh the biggest issue
I have with this is the transfer of
wealth that so I understand you know
centralizing Walmart Target and
everything you know people are going to
get sick the problem is they just did
what 1.9 trillion dollars in stimulus so
they're going to give people 1400 bucks
I guess it's gonna be means tested that
money is going to go to Walmart that
money is going to go to Amazon it's
gonna go to Target it's not going to go
to Mom and Pops you know Barbershop Mom
and Pops computer repair whatever small
business has been gutted and eviscerated
and I think if you look at everything
they're doing
why why charge someone two grand for
this you know quarantine specialty kit
I'll tell you one 2.4 2.4 000. I don't I
I can only tell you the simple solution
they're trying to prevent covid I can
say one of the X one of the side effects
of everything they're doing stopping
people from traveling traveling around
the world or locally stopping people
from buying things stopping people from
going out and servicing uh bars and
restaurants ultimately reducing the
amount that is being consumed reducing
the amount of carbon emissions and the
New York Times wrote the story a while
ago the earth is healing because of the
lockdown that was early on when it was
15 days to sell the spread we're still
slowing the spread a year later I
suppose but it seems like whether it's
intended or not they can say it's for
all these things the one thing that's
really happening is a great reset yep
and it's blatant too which blows my mind
when people again get so caught up in
the ways that we've been paid against
each other it's like we're in this
because this one person I know doesn't
like to wear a mask we're in this
because you're being selfish and you
went to a party because you were
depressed for six months in your
apartment you just had to see someone no
like your neighbor is not the enemy
at all well according to Disney I guess
it is because we're all mad when Gina
Carano called that out right and maybe
your neighbor is your enemy if they you
know plow your snow or whatever but
right yeah seriously for those who don't
know the context some LA Times
columnists was freaking out because her
Trump supporting neighbor is politely
plowed her driveway
the end of the world my friends wow yeah
it's the it's modern politics I'm like
muting myself right now because of the
stuff that I want to say I can't say on
YouTube well we'll save it for the
members only segments that's right where
we're more freed yeah I want to hear
that yeah yeah that's the that's the
reality it's all about code this is
there's a simple a simple breakdown for
people who they always get mad when
they're like why won't you guys say what
you need to do what you need to say I'll
make it simple we can we can sacrifice
the 99 things we we say to you every
night for one thing we can say on
timcast.com it's not even that I want to
say claims about what I think about if
it's real or if it's not I just I wanna
postulate that maybe it's you know
there's there's something wrong here and
just be postulating is like treading on
dangerous water when it comes to it's a
great time that is that we can't just
speak freely I've stopped myself from
saying several things on here and this
is you know in a sphere of the internet
that is the most open about this kind of
thing and yet we still can't say exactly
what we feel when I'm you know drunk
with my friends on my balcony really
talking about this stuff I'm not saying
the stuff I'm saying here you know what
I mean oh yeah and so you're lying about
everything
I'm dulling it down I'm wearing a mask
turn it down a little bit right so we'll
we'll just go ham with it
well I I I'll tell you this there's uh
there's there's limits I mean this whole
this whole show we've been talking about
censorship and repression of speech and
everything like that and so this is this
is the conversation I've had with a lot
of people going back several years when
there's like a certain name I can't say
and people are like stop being weak and
just say them name and I'm like and then
I will never be able to speak to you
about anything and there's a lot of
important things to talk about so we be
careful about some things and that's why
I was like we got to start our own our
own platform that if we get banned on
here at least we can say whatever we
want on you know a private website
fortunately uh well I should say there's
good news and bad news the good news is
the platform exists we can go at
timcast.com and say this stuff
but still the audience there is a
microscopic fraction right of the people
who watch this show of course it's
absolutely ridiculous that we have to
tiptoe meanwhile the mainstream media
gets to say whatever they want seriously
they get to whatever they want no
accountability they lie to you they get
to tell you there's weapons of mass
destruction they get to tell you not to
wear masks then to wear masks they get
to flip-flop and lie and protect the
special interest work for powers that be
and and yet they don't get fact checked
and yet they don't get corrected yet
they don't face any ramifications any
consequences for anything that they do
they get to eat human brain
literally a human brain on TV sure did
you know that no no I thought you're
making some comments no no no no no no
no no CNN host I think he went we talked
about before he went videos on YouTube
how did he get hold of a human brain it
was a sect of these these like Hindu
zealots and he was I guess he was like
sitting down as a show about religions
and they took a piece of brain and they
and they they cooked it they charred it
and then gave it to him and he ate it
but where did the brain rain come from
like you may kill someone I don't know a
cadaver maybe died yeah and he literally
ate it on TV and I think the dude went
nuts I think it made him not I think
well yeah you're not supposed to do that
the same way you can't feed a cow a cow
but I don't think he got I don't think
he got mad human you know brain disease
I think he got uh PTSD from it I think
he was traumatized maybe how could you
not be right you could he could never
come back he's a cannibal Reza Aslan is
a cannibal he is a cannibal yeah that's
one of those lines like of humanity that
once you cross that it's like you're
probably not the same person I know I
know somebody who's friends with him
right and I was talking about this and I
said dude's a cannibal and they were
like he is not a cannibal and I was like
did he eat human he ate he ate some
brain from a human and I said so if
there's a dude and he takes a child into
a into a room and abuses him would you
not say he's a diddler it was only one
kid and they were like oh no of course
I'm okay he ate human one time he's a
cannibal right it only takes one time
but he's not he doesn't seek out human
and consume it on like day to day
[Applause]
if a man was sitting down with a group
of people and they said take this knife
and and kill that person and he did
would you call him a murderer
oh yeah it was one time someone in the
past it doesn't mean that he's not aware
of a murderer well there's different
ways to look at it bro once you're let
out of prison you can say they're
they're an ex-con they're no longer a
convict they committed the crime in the
past they're no longer a crime committer
sure what do you mean well their next
convict when they leave prison
it is so disgusting but he's a cannibal
so say he is still a cannibal I think
can drive him insane if he's thinking
like I'm a cannibal I can never shape
but like yeah man you ate it in the
human don't eat it in the future
I guess I guess you can say former you
know former cannibal it might have gave
him mental problems because you can't
feed a cow a cow you can't feed a monkey
a monkey like it's just one of those
things about like life that just once
you cross that what is it called
aren't they prions yes
it's not good whatever it is yeah let's
read about prion it's a bridge too is it
I don't know maybe it's not Encephalitis
I don't know that's a that's a that's
not Encephalitis sorry you get the
shakes like what's that movie is it uh
The Book of Eli you could be like you
ever see that movie it was awesome this
year says a prion is a misfolded protein
with the ability to transmit their
misfolded shape onto normal variants he
doesn't have that because you die from
that but I think he was he got PTSD from
it but anyway the main point is because
I'm always willing to talk
the main point is they aired this and it
was like it's on YouTube YouTube allows
this to be on their platform yeah and
you know that's really obscene I mean of
of all the things that should or
shouldn't be censored or shown on TV
that's obscene yeah a guy eating people
that's insane you know
we got problems yeah yeah that's that's
promoted by YouTube that's in the
algorithm you look up any kind of news
event you look up anything no no I don't
I don't think it's promoted I think
someone no no it is promoted because
when you look at similar topics with
alternative media it's suppressed so
when you have information that's
suppressed from independent creators and
promoted by of course Mainline
institutions that are allowed to do
whatever they want that that's promotion
I'm sorry the mainstream media has a
rigged oh I'm sorry it's the New York
Post 1.5 million views yeah it is Reza
Aslan eats human brains while profiling
Hindu agori cannibals a few years ago I
remember playing the CNN clip on YouTube
and of course it probably came up uh
it's like I resolution too yeah you look
up any relevant news event never will
Independent Media come up never even
though there were on the ground even
though they got original coverage even
though they got actual reporting on this
topic on the ground make sure
Independent Media is never going to come
up it's always going to be CNN even just
stealing independent reporters footage
like they did to me they did this to me
a couple times and it's so frustrating
because I used to be on the ground
reporting live mainstream media just
stole my stuff and then an assault
search algorithms in the play next it
was always them
even took my video and like I remember
no no this is a funny story just I'll
mention it real quick Al Jazeera
Luke's video and then got his video
removed yes and then and then it took
and it and then and then YouTube took
away my monetization from that video and
then for for three months so didn't
allow me to even have that video yes
totally stop the views and then and then
there was no way there was no
accountability there was no way to fix
that CNN also did a similar thing they
went after one of my live streams it was
it was I believe the not not the
inauguration but the uh the the the
speech of the Union State of the Union
addressed by the president I was playing
that CNN said it was theirs shut me down
for a month couldn't live stream uh
based off of fake uh strike that didn't
have any marriage I got it I gotta let
you in on a secret Loop this is actually
the fault of
uh you yeah so of course I see you no no
no no no hold on hold on if you want
your channel to appear in the in the in
the authoritative news you actually just
have to fill out a form on Google News
and it's not particularly difficult no
one knows this though so I've actually
talked to Google because you know we're
working on setting up these various
sites and they said you go to Google
News you apply you fill out the form you
link to your website and then they
include you in their list
so so when you search for news and you
get all these approved sources it's
because they got their names added to
the list now don't get me wrong Google
will probably be like this guy get out
of here he was the guy who was yelling
at Eric Schmidt you're not going to put
it yeah I asked him a very pointed
logical question that was needed to be
asked to him at that moment at that time
and I was being respectful he's former
CEO of Google I told him not to curse
yes
former head of alphabet and Google and
now he's working with the Pentagon
working on the technological
advancements of the military so uh
Bilderberg member as well a lot of
secret societies uh that he's also
connected to but that's a whole other
side thing but but yet again I just
asked them a legitimate question that
deserved to be asked in the bear yeah I
mean that's what a journalist is
supposed to do yeah I faced the
repercussions well let's let's talk
about project Veritas yeah so uh
actually I wonder if I have an article I
think I I did well as you look looking
for the article it's important to know a
lot of people got hit today Robert F
Kennedy Jr Dell big tree James O'Keefe
project Veritas there's other reports of
Tom McDonald having some of his videos
taken down from Spotify and apple music
I think they're back up now but also
other individuals like Immortal
Technique and R.A the rugged Man had
their video flagged and because it was
supposedly election disinformation their
music video wasn't even about the
election no it's just politics
a lot of things were about the CIA but
that's a whole nother side topic but
they said it was election disinformation
so and then they so and then I've got
important breaking news yes
um project Veritas is not permanently
banned from Twitter good that's good so
CNN is wrong
um as far as I know I mean so uh I know
James CNN's wrong I know James O'Keefe
no and we're uh we've had him on the
show before and I think he's a cool dude
I think he's a good dude I think it is
great work apparently he's not
permanently banned they suspended his
account because as they wanted a certain
you know we have to remove a certain
tweet the tweet in question is he
confronted a Facebook employee
like any other news organization with
other operations or something yeah yeah
so he was they had one of their
employees saying like hey can you answer
these questions and the guy's like yeah
it was in front of his house now when I
saw that I was like oh but they were at
his house James quickly in his video
points out BBC does it Fox News does it
CNN does it everybody it is a normal
thing where they go to people's houses
and they ask them questions and they do
the exact same thing and so he says in
this video they will not be taking it
down because they will not set
themselves to a lower standard than any
other news organization they're going to
operate much the same way as anyone else
would so they appealed it yes apparently
because they appealed the decision
Twitter now says the account has
suspended my understanding is it's not
permanent but CNN claims it is so I
wonder if maybe it really is I mean I'd
have to imagine not they say they say
this look this uh Twitter permanently
banned an account on Thursday belonging
to project Veritas they say the decision
followed what a Twitter spokesperson
described to CNN business as repeated
violations of the platform's policies
prohibiting sharing or threats of
sharing other people's private
information Twitter declined to say what
specific tweets may have been may have
triggered the enforcement action but in
a post on Project Veritas public
telegram Channel Thursday afternoon the
group said the suspension occurred after
it published a video in which project
Veritas accosted I'm certain I'm certain
project Fair test didn't say they had
costed anybody sure Facebook VP of
integrity at his home they say Twitter
also confirmed that O'Keefe's personal
account had been locked temporarily for
violating the same policy and then
O'Keefe would be required to remove the
violative content before regaining
permission to tweet in an email
statement to CNN business O'Keefe again
said it was false that the video
contained private information and claims
Twitter told the group it could have its
account reinstated if it deleted the
Tweet containing the video so it's
interesting that Twitter has refused
like decline to say what what the result
what the reason was
Veritas said no no it's not permanently
banned but CNN still runs the headline
that it is permanently banned I guess
we'll just have to wait and see it by
the way this is the same CNN that showed
up at at a memer's house someone who
made memes at their house was it also
them or was it another organization that
threatened to dox them unless they take
down the meme
I mean I mean that's the same news
organization that's talking about
accosting other individuals I mean you
gotta be kidding me I mean layers of
hypocrisy are insane didn't they go to
that old lady's house because she was
sharing Russian memes or whatever she
was like a member of a page that the
Russians were running so they like show
up at her house and she's like what what
are you talking about they're like ma'am
you're supporting Russian propaganda and
it's like old lady and she's like what
and she goes in her house and like
ignores them um you're crazy so just to
clarify do I haven't watched enough news
to know but do they go to someone's
house stand outside get a full video
shot of the house yes yeah so it's like
they don't but they blur out the address
nope they'll show the address online so
that's doxing yep yeah it's not illegal
right in Sweden they they they hacked
the disc hack discus a commenting system
and then they doxed Anonymous commenters
and showed up to their houses filming is
that illegal to publish someone's
private information no because it's
technically public information yeah
um it happens to be accompanied with
like a threat or something like that but
if it's just that because I've been docs
five six times and it's you can't really
do anything unless it's accompanied with
this is the person's address and people
should go but but does Twitter have no
doxing in their terms of service they're
not allowed to docs yeah private
information but James didn't include any
private information I didn't see any
address I didn't see license plates it
was actually blurred bars and they were
blurred license plates everything was
blurred I mean it doesn't even matter
because the real point is much like uh
Gina we were talking about earlier it's
just about anyone who's defiant they're
gonna try to crush you so the fact that
they're not already banned actually
amazes me well so it's funny they're
going after Tucker Carlson because he
made comments about George Floyd and I
did a video about this earlier and I I
don't look Veritas there was no large
Uprising where they were alike we must
ban James O'Keefe he just got quietly
suspended really really quickly the
reason is James O'Keefe is an actual
threat to them because he actually
produces video content without his
opinion in it he might editorialize he
might you know he reads the the copy and
he's the one doing the voiceover but
when they show you a video of a VP of
Facebook saying things that's not an
opinion that's the person actually
saying I mean it might be the vp's
opinion or the employees opinion but
it's not veritas's opinion Tucker
Carlson his opinion is an opinion guy
he's an excellent Boogeyman for the left
so they can go oh no look at Tucker
saying these things everyone quit donut
give me money and you know subscribe to
my my patreon so that we can complain
about Tucker and then you know CNN's uh
Media Fox News Review show is like I
can't believe Tucker would say that they
don't want Tucker Band
they need him he's a boogeyman Veritas
on the other hand they can't Boogeyman
him they try they definitely do but they
can't show you what he's actually doing
with Tucker they show clips from his
show and they're like look at that
opinion what are you gonna do Tucker's
allowed to have an opinion it could be a
dumb opinion you know how to like it but
it's very different yeah they want to
keep Tucker around in my opinion because
he's a pressure release valve for the
populist right as is a show like this in
my opinion not everybody on the Bible is
right because we did rag on Trump quite
a bit and we do reckon Republicans but
it still functions as in essence a
pressure release valve for though those
who are freaking out about censorship
Tucker is one show on one channel up
against the entirety of the machine they
demonize him as a boogeyman to keep
people on their side in line while
allowing him to act as a pressure
release valve Veritas is an actual
journalistic Outlet producing damning
information and exposing the corrupt
nuked yeah the um I think they do Fair
unbiased journalism and for me if it
this is like my Fox News or Veritas
veritas this is my litmus test for
Twitter if if they ban his account for
that I'll stop using Twitter completely
I have no problem I raised my account
from like 400 followers to 10 000 in the
last six months I've been heavily using
Twitter but what's your Twitter Ian
Crossland if they uh if they blow this I
think I'm going to mines 100 full-time
yes you know that's the that's the issue
too a lot of us got to put our money
where our mouth is and be more active on
other platforms that's just that's just
it I don't even care about Twitter
interactions I don't even know why I use
it I probably should just start posting
on Minds more just that's it I'll do it
yeah I'm building up my email list and I
definitely recommend everyone else do
the same and I'm Twitter Instagram I'm
just I'm just gonna be extra spicy I
have been I've been having a lot of fun
with that if it goes It goes but I have
my email list we are changed.org top
right hand corner means a lot to me I
got a better idea we talked about we
talked about this a bit on the on a show
last week or so why don't we just create
a
can we create some kind of like
Federated plug-in for websites should so
instead of telling people follow me on
Twitter I just say follow me on
timcast.com
yeah like an RSS we're talking about
rebuilding RSS so basically what we
could do is we could create
a feed where I can just pull up an app
on my phone and I can like I would
normally tweet but I would just go to my
own it would go to timcast.com yeah and
we can all do it so if you go there
you'll see all of us but then we can
also do the same thing for all of our
guests but then on their website they do
the same thing and so basically there is
no one social site it's just essentially
RSS where everyone's getting access to
this feed where people are commenting
and posting things we actually talked
about rss3 like going so we should talk
to our incredibly talented developers
that we have in the house to get some
advice and take that move forward with
that because I think that's a great idea
one of the things that we were talking
about doing is creating a like a white
label software open source that people
can just they can buy a domain buy
server space and then install the
package and then instantly have a full
social media site but it's on their
server space so if the hosting company
bans them well that's you know there you
go you can still get banned but Twitter
can't do it Facebook can't do it and
then what we do is we just Network them
together in some capacity it would be
weaker than Twitter Facebook or YouTube
because the the networking is is limited
compared to what you can do on Twitter
like hosting videos and stuff but we can
still make a rudimentary system that
would work this way that's that I I
think it's probably a good idea we
should probably do it I like that one of
the reasons I started timcast.com was
because I'm like okay well I can always
post here if I get banned so instead of
saying [ __ ] you know follow me on
Twitter just follow me on timcast.com go
to the website we need to make something
that Aggregates posts from websites I
suppose so we have like the members only
section maybe we can make a directory
that incorporates memberships or like
content posts from a ton of different
creators influencers you know com
whatever commentators that way you have
one app where you can follow everybody
but all it is is a directory not
actually you know a social media website
follow their website activity all
through a decentralized or you're gonna
say something well I was just I don't
want to Sidetrack uh finish your points
but I want to talk about the Florida
travel restrictions uh why did you look
into it uh no I was I was hoping maybe
we could pull up a story and then read
it we will in a second crazy I guess I
guess we're pretty close to wrapping
this off this one up as it is I guess
the general idea is
is there anybody who wants you know
especially those listening who wants to
put together an open source very simple
white label package that you can install
into a server that gives you the
functionality of Twitter Facebook or
YouTube and then we can create a parent
directory that just Aggregates those so
basically we make a website called like
you know Ian's amazing you know
funhouseadventure.com and when you go
there if you set up one of these
software one of these white label
software programs on your server you
just put your domain you submit your
domain to the site it gets edited the
directory and then people can follow and
then you go to this website and you'll
see a list of all the posts from these
websites and then what they could ban
the directory I suppose but the website
still exists new directories would pop
up and you can't ban it simple as that
you could host video you'd have to pay
to host your own video that's of course
and you have to pay you'd have to pay to
host your own everything but hey look if
you're gonna pay I mean how much how
much is going to cost to host text just
text not much right if at all that's
gonna be like 10 bucks for the domain
and then like you know what 10 bucks a
month or something for server space
right and then all you're doing is
posting your tweets no one can ban you
that's what iTunes is saying they're
like you know they're trying to get
podcasts to banned but iTunes is like
we're a directory we we list RSS feeds
we don't actually host anything we what
do you want to ban well stop listing it
it's literally just plugins you know
whatever where do they host the our the
stuff from iTunes the podcast where are
those hosted that they're pulling on
people's own servers yeah people's own
websites oh so you're hosting like the
Tim cast show on a proprietary server
like Amazon AWS or something it's a
proprietary server but iTunes
facilitates it for you and all I do is
provide the RSS link to the podcast
platforms oh so you have someone else
holding the server for you and then you
provide a link to iTunes there is an RSS
link that is given to the podcast
platforms and then they post it
but I mean I'm wondering how do you get
your podcast online proprietary server
that's you finding a proprietary service
somewhere else upload to a proprietary
server that that you get access to and
then you send the link to the podcast so
you get access to you have to actually
go get it's not through iTunes it's
something separate and I'm not going to
reveal exactly how I don't care about
private I don't care the name of it but
you're saying you you go outside of
iTunes you send RSS link to iTunes and
iTune just shows the link that's not it
end of story uh you want to talk about
uh floor a little bit yeah I mean
there's there's some scuttlebell there's
some rumors According to some
um Anonymous reports from inside the
White House that the Biden
Administration is considering imposing
domestic travel restrictions to Florida
to stop the spread of covet 19. uh
there's a lot of uh responses and
official statements made by a lot of
Florida government officials not a lot
of government officials from the White
House that allegedly are going to be
imposing this so it's still unconfirmed
but but that's well that's
do this let's why don't we dive into
this uh uh on the on the website because
we're at Super Chat time let me just
read one one paragraph here from this
NPR article that says De Santos the the
governor of Florida pointed that the
coronavirus related emergency room
visits in Florida have dropped by more
than half since December he said he's
100 opposed to any restrictions
domestically so that's uh the Santos
that's what he said good for him just
wanted to make that statement a tease to
what we're going to be talking about
afterwards he's a rock star I love him
well let's go to super chats if you
haven't already smash the like button
hit that notification Bell subscribe all
of that stuff and like I said go to
timcast.com because we're going to have
that segment where we the reason why I
was saying we should save this for the
bonus segment is or the members only
segment is because we're going to say a
whole bunch of stuff YouTube probably
will be unhappy with so uh let's give
ourselves that space to do it because it
sounds like a freaky story other than
that we are going to uh get up on these
uh we're going to get over
to these super chats and uh let's see we
got
Carlos Mencia oh wow Vehicles man CSS I
know how to build and design what you're
talking about where can I get in touch
um you know what
for anybody who's interested email jobs
at timcast.com I've actually set it up
that's gonna get inundated but I'm I'm
you know what man I was actually we were
driving back and I was like why don't we
just fund like our own TV show why don't
we just like they banned that they fired
Gina you know Carano and I'm like why
don't we just make our own shows we
don't got Hollywood budgets but it's not
hard to make that's what the daily wire
is starting to do which I think is a
really positive move I forgot we were
alive by the way until you said super
chats I like completely forgot I was
like you're like I'm just sitting here
yeah even if we make really bad ones and
really cringy ones they would still be a
lot better than the propaganda in
Hollywood yeah
is really really frustrating because
YouTube has changed the layout for super
chats so I can't actually read the name
of the Super Chat that's weird yeah it
sucks
yeah why did they do that that's
horrible people deserve to have their
names Google is not know how to run a
social network they never have yeah well
you know in the beginning they did when
you know you actually got to see what
you subscribed to all right we got it
they just bought YouTube YouTube knew
how Google bought it and then started to
ruin it yeah we got Darth halek says Tom
McDonald's new song has been removed
from all major Music Services his
message is too powerful please get him
as a guest uh sounds cool we know Tom
and I'll tell you this right now
you think Tom's cool he is come on we
have a ton of other people we've all
reached out to
a ton of really awesome people
can't travel right now that's true
so a lot of people are like why uh I
don't I don't want to mention anything
too specific about people's families or
whatever but there's a lot of there's a
lot of issues where people are taking
Health very seriously yeah so there's
been like a dozen I really get it really
amazing guests I'm super excited for
some people I'm just like there there's
like you know one particular person I've
been a fan of for a decade and they're
like I'd love to do the show but covid
and here are the reasons and I'm like
those are legitimate oh that sucks so
I'm just the backup yes oh yeah
definitely definitely we were like what
what crazy person would fly from across
the country in Blair we were like oh
yeah we'll get Blair she'll totally do
it she'll do it absolutely yeah no we're
stuck to have you of course I love Tom
McDonald by the way I think what he's
doing is awesome I just discovered him
last week I don't know why I'm late on
the train me too and I message him on
Instagram I was like good job and he's
like my girlfriend's freaking out she
loves you I was like
so it sounds great yeah and his videos
are so good and did you know
um his girlfriend films all of them yeah
those two doing all of it no no big
production right and the liability is so
good that's why I'm safe on the show
that's why I'm saying let's start making
stuff so jobs at timcast.com what do we
need we'll just start pitching ideas I
don't know if someone wants to build the
flux capacitor or invent a time machine
same thing you know whatever song I mean
I mean he yells facts don't care about
your feelings you know right that's the
chorus so all right let's see we got
vbdc says check out my interviews with
Ian and zertus on talkie time only on IG
big up Tim crew is that something used
on Instagram yeah oh yeah right on
Justin Meyer says who is this Blair
chick she's got
um was it supposed to be an H I think he
typo that's great what's got mean hot oh
maybe yeah
that's right
Gareth green says Hey Blair I've been
following you since 2017.
oh thank you Gareth is one of our mega
super Chatters super chats a lot so
great nice thank you so much Jay says I
have been canceling my Disney plus sub
after each episode of the Mandalorian
the service doesn't offer me anything
else that is worthwhile now I have more
reason to stay unsubscribed Cancel
season three you know I'm uh
I kind of feel bad that I subscribed in
the first place I was not subscribed to
Disney plus and then when when Jack was
like actually mandalorian's pretty good
I was like I should I should say season
two I was like I should watch it I'm you
know and Gina Chrono was great in it I
thought she I thought she was great I
thought she was good in Deadpool and
then I when when this happened people
started saying you should cancel Disney
plus because of the uyghur Muslim thing
and their support for the paramilitary
group and I was like oh why did I
subscribe to this in the first place
because they still get to keep my money
even though I canceled you know I just
wanted to watch Cheetah Girls I'm sorry
something simple
dis-his says I don't like Blair white
but you guys should be able to handle
other opinions sounds like a cancel
culture live chat gotta chill oh I'm
sorry I don't I don't like Blair white
either but you guys should be able to
handle other other opinions sounds like
cancel culture live chat gotta chill
oh geez all right well not everyone's
gonna love you I mean Ian Gets a lot of
a lot of flack Welcome to Hell
so much better to be someone that
everyone has a strong opinion about than
the opposite I mean that's good for
Ratings I mean it's followed up by uh
from Mega transition I love mommy Blair
so yeah right it's lover
garhant says Gina was fired day before
q1 Disney release rumor is internal
Disney employee released it before q1 to
save her Disney was firing her before
interesting no but she got canned from
UTA that's brutal you like losing your
talent agency UTA is a big deal yeah I'm
not a fan and uh I'm more a fan of
making your own stuff
yeah we need to build our own Industries
we need to build our own you know
infrastructure for all the stuff man I
had management CBS management X they'd
been at CBS before and they dropped me
when I was making YouTube videos with a
black guy talking about getting hit in
the face they were like too racy to that
industry sucks yep it's like a big snake
that you want to ride that will bite you
and throw you off if you mess with it
true yeah enabled Diamond says Sour
Patch Lids I at you on Twitter can you
please show my dog I had to put her down
today just please show how happy she is
that's how I want her Remembered at Luke
Paul Scott forever can you sorry I gotta
pull it up I'm sorry I didn't see that
go by will you try and find it on your
phone we'll figure out what it is and
then we'll pull it up sure that's sad
yeah
sorry about that yeah man dogs are man
Man's Best Friend yeah
Damon Court says there is a civil war in
lucasfilms and she is she is popular on
one side and conservative Kennedy's
faction hates almost everyone with
Mandalorian
that's so weird
Jared Thiel Thiel says hey Tim was
talking with a friend from MKE and went
to UWM and basically told me that it's
student bodies and student Governors who
started the local riots interesting
Janet McMahon says is that Blair's voice
I hear it is Blair hi Blair
is there audio only for this I love it
yeah after the podcast the podcast yeah
yeah
so really I mean but it's because people
when they listen to milk a show like
this even though it's live yeah
cyrilio says I love when separate
YouTubers I watch get together it's like
the old school crossover episode of your
favorite show as a kid yes I always love
it too I'm like that person who knows
that person I love it I think I'm just
gonna have to keep skipping forward
because the next one is Blair and heart
and just yeah just basically everybody
like you know Blair's great
thank you
Shaker silver says why focus on Pedro go
for the jugular Disney has not answered
for support of the uyghur camps and the
lead actress of Mulan supporting Hong
Kong police all true yeah not good well
another shout out we have Clayton
Redding says uh Reddick says serpent saw
in lawai 86 would be awesome guests true
you have a lot of follower overlap that
would be that would be very uh that
would be very happy about it very true
yeah what's up are we gonna hook him up
yeah yeah
I know I know I've reached out yeah good
I want Elliot holes yes I know he's
another YouTuber he's like a strength
camp he's super cool I like him
let's see Zero zerosopher says love you
Tim but Occam's razor is not the
simplest solution is often the correct
one it is quote competing hypotheses
about the same prediction one should
select the solution with the fewest
assumptions Simple Solutions can have
huge assumptions that's a very very good
point and thank you for the correction
because I have been oversimplifying the
statement for sure yes the one that
makes a few assumptions is is a better
way of saying it yes
are our bracewell been saying this is
pre-World War II Germany speak up and
speak out don't let them take your voice
don't let them tell you you're wrong who
cares if you don't have a Facebook or
Twitter shut them up and shut them down
before they get you do not go quietly
there are a bunch of people I know who
are prominent and powerful and like you
were saying about Hollywood half as
conservative they seem to think and I'll
tell you this you guys are wrong that if
they shut up and sit down then the tide
will pass over them it will not it'll
get you it's you know that Meme of death
going door to door yeah that's what's
happening and for some reasons people
are like well he's gonna skip this one
because I'm not making any noise nice
he's opening every single one you don't
actually need a reason they can make up
things too yeah you know what I mean
just like Chris Pratt when everyone was
going after him from being a suspected
conservative and he was getting hate for
that it's like they're all Gonna Get You
Tom Brady yes right yeah I know it was
racist of him to win the Super Bowl
right they can just make it up I lost
three months they were they were like
Colin Kaepernick was trending after the
Super Bowl and they were saying like
happy Colin Kaepernick appreciation day
I'm like why well it you can praise him
as an activist I don't care but he
doesn't play football right see I don't
know anything about the Super Bowl I
didn't even know what was happening when
it was happening but I told my friend I
was like oh the Super Bowl's on they'll
make it about race somehow and then it
happened it was just so predictable
unavoidable yeah Jordan Fowler says Tim
and crew are any of you worried that the
government considers you to be too
radical because of what you say and come
after you with the FBI or ATF saying
you're dangerous because you own guns
I'm not worried No No in fact I think
things have improved for me because when
I first went to buy guns I was heavily
delayed it took like five days not
anymore right now it's like they punch
it in and the FBI guys that it's called
Knicks they're just like oh it's Tim
again hey we were joking that they're
probably like at this point they're
probably like oh hey it's Tim we watch a
show yeah here you go get your guns or
whatever yeah correct I'm not worried uh
I you know I don't I don't know what do
you think Luke are you working we uh you
know dot our eyes cross our T's we don't
do anything illegal uh we're overly
careful uh about making sure we follow
every little made-up rule doesn't matter
uh rules are made up uh we we make sure
that we're squeaky clean and we are and
there's nothing that could get they
could get us on yeah I've been uh
basically invited to Bilderberg so I'm
not concerned
very cool Ian's Ian's part of the the
Illuminati so oh snap
Dimitri kudzik says hi Tim love your
idea on making short films that are not
affected by today's divisive uh
political climate by the way where can
one send a pitch script I am a
professional 3D animator and VFX artist
will be happy to help with CG if you
need it you know honestly I don't even
know where to begin with something like
this because I'm not I made I've made
documentaries I've never made fiction
stuff the documentaries I've made have
have always been field reporting you
know verite kind of stuff or hosted
stuff
in terms of putting together a short
film I don't know where to begin you can
send everything to me at Lydia
timcast.com which everyone latched on to
after Tim said that in his morning well
actually we have jobs at timcast.com we
do yes yes I've created something
specific so I I think however we'll need
to make pitches or pitch at timcast.com
soon we don't have that now but jobs
will suffice because not everyone is
trying to pitch a story and to be
completely honest I don't know if we're
at the point where we can actually go
through that and get to it I think the
first thing we need to do is hire a um
a production specialist you know someone
who can do it and knows what they need
to make short films and see a series and
I'd love to actually fund maybe like a
10 episode series of some sort We're Not
Gonna it's not a big budget but you look
at shows like the office and their
budget is mostly the star power you know
the actors and their costumes I was
watching that last night it's not hard
to do something you know really simple
with a couple cameras and we have the
resources to do it so let's just do it
we could make you know I was thinking
about I think you mentioned this earlier
before around the show you said comedy
is like dying or dead Blair and then I
was like well there's Ryan long you know
Tim Dylan yeah JP Sears yeah definitely
JP Sears yeah yeah and so there's a few
he's yeah so I'm like well maybe that's
the kind of humor that we can do in a
sitcom that doesn't exist in TV or
Disney or Hulu because they're they're
terrified little babies and look if
people I'll make what people want to
watch if they want to watch it and if it
works we'll make more you know it sounds
fun I think it's a good idea
there we go we just got to build our own
infrastructure definitely like Tom
McDonald doing his thing independently
yes exactly
oh we got a big old Super Chat from
Emmanuel zayas appreciate it thank you
very much you sir
the good says Marco Rubio was the main
one who has been in charge of censorship
he was the one who called the expert
witness that famously said we must
silence the Cannons on social media 800
journalists from both sides of the aisle
were banned immediately after wow really
whoa I didn't know that I didn't know
that jeez
kdb says so happy to see Blair on I
watch every single one of you of you of
both of your videos wish I wasn't
working so I could watch it all live now
to make one more dream come true Luke if
you haven't decided yet please scare Tim
with shoe on head ah okay well well what
does that mean well he wants you to come
on the show oh no Tim stormed my RV with
Alex Jones and woke me up when I was
taking a nap and now I gotta find
someone to bring on the chair to scare
the crap out of Tim when he's got your
back
well she was always welcome to come on
the show but we have a lot of invites
out so standing in contact me oh yeah
kcb says I nuked all my social media a
month ago and the joy I have in life has
been wildly increased also happy 40th
birthday to my beautiful wife of 20
years happy birthday oh my gosh love it
Jack Benson venga says would you want to
have Gina Carano on the show as a guest
I saw a segment of Stephen Crowder where
he said he'd hire her I saw that too he
was like I don't care for what your hide
will give you any job oh my God all
right I would it'd be amazing show I
absolutely love to uh I tweeted at her
it's the only real way uh you know it's
hard but uh you know I'm sure this has
been pretty crummy for her so I don't
wanna she's going through it I'm sure
but hey you don't want to be asking for
favors yeah yeah but but maybe maybe uh
it could also be an opportunity to speak
freely for a couple hours explain you
know she went on the Babylon B podcast I
guess recently right before everything
yeah yeah yeah so look he wants the dust
settles and she's kind of like because
it can't feel good she's probably really
going through it yeah I mean maybe she's
not maybe she's like she seems kind of
tough I wonder if she was just like she
does not got angry I'll get ready I'm
sure she's devastated I went through it
prematurely I had to leave the
entertainment industry after I had like
management with CBS and booking
commercials and television but I just
skipped speaking honestly on YouTube
they've stopped working with me
basically and I realized I had to make a
choice go down there and be subservient
or do the free speech thing I did free
speech I lost all the money all the
notoriety almost killed myself and now
now it's it's I've realized I did the
right thing by sticking to the my honest
truth so she's like just entering that
that like
she fought uh eight MMA matches and won
seven of them
yeah so my thing's always like if
tomorrow I got Perma ban from every
platform and then my hosting everyone
everything went down I'd be like let's
go fishing you can't you know yeah I've
always been like that too it's like yeah
everything ended right now yeah but what
if they took all your money away well
that's different well they took all your
houses all your money tomorrow all of my
houses
you'd be like what would you do with
your life uh I go skate you'd probably
try and get it back no I would imagine
you wouldn't turn over and give up but
it depends like
you know I'd love to just go hang out at
the skate park and just skate all day
you know I would go to Bali and live for
pennies on the dollar yeah
Costa Rica you know the the issue is
I'll tell you this to be honest you need
money to a certain degree so if
everything got banned I'd probably do
some Consulting work make it make enough
to you know sustain myself for a decent
amount and probably just go skate would
you would you continue to try the same
methodology or would you do like some
totally different lifestyle I don't know
I'd probably just go skate go fishing
and live in a van down by the river
I got the van it's ready to go I guess
they can't take your van buried they can
try very true I don't know they took
everything away from me it's an extreme
I go live in the woods but yeah you know
build a build a mud hut yeah all right
Publius the good says well we need a
freedom party this issue is that Biden
used his power under the Obama
Administration to use the IRS to destroy
the tea party I don't see a realistic
solution when the ruling class will
unlawfully try to destroy all the
opposition I hear you on that one man
sure man
Swifty says I think the only the only
thing about Disney as it is now that
Walt Disney himself would be
disappointed or angry with is that most
of the management is is I is either
Jewish or female very sad speakable Walt
Disney was a raging anti-semite nsxist
so yeah you know so that's that's the
point yep
publish the good says plus plus plus
plus five thousand for your guest well
said heck yeah people think you are
great Blair oh thank you that's very
true Chris pavoto says calling you guys
out Hypocrites for bashing Twitter but
still using it you all have other means
to reach fans why keep it smack talking
it but helping them in ad revenue and
please don't just say it's the new
social Gathering Place no I I think
you're right absolutely and I think
that's why I'm gonna focus more on the
timcast.com I'm gonna see if we can
build the system where we can all post
stuff you know like a Twitter like Style
just on the website so I would just be
like follow me on my website and we have
our our post of content all day and our
jokes and you can comment and respond
that's probably the way to do it man we
already have a comment section we just
need to create you know just blog posts
and uh yeah I should probably use mines
more than Twitter from now on probably
just use Twitter for
reading the news I understand that
hypocritical statement it's that kind of
wrecks me during my life where I think
you know we live off the backs of child
slaves this clothing was made probably
in a factory somewhere like people I
don't know
but I do it anyway we type on plastic
that's that's we're sorry Tim what were
you gonna say let's move on so I don't
know we're all Hypocrites yeah yeah we
are this is a good one IB Drago says
Bill Gates is Mr rabbit in Utopia he
literally checks off all the boxes yes
do you know what that is Mr Abby so you
Utopia the the new one that came out on
Amazon is about this like Tech Mogul guy
or he like he's making fake meat and uh
am I spoiling the show if I tell
everybody well spoiler alert spoil it if
you don't want to know if you don't want
to watch Utopia basically they call him
Mr rabbit and he manufactured uh like
their staging a virus or I think they
manufactured it so that they can give
people a vaccine that sterilizes them
yes you know so yeah something like dark
yeah yeah they canceled it because
people were like yo this is too close to
reality right it's a little close to
home a little bit or I guess it made
people like think it was real whatever
people are silly well actually so the
show is about a comic book that is
basically predicting what's going on and
so the point people are making was it's
a show about a fictional medium
predicting that there is going to be a
fake a fake disease where they'll use it
as a pretext for giving everyone a
vaccine that sterilizes them and now in
the real world there is this show which
is saying everything that happened and
it's you know there's a there's a
vaccine coming out so people got freaked
out by it are you all gonna get the
vaccine no way uh no I have food
allergies I have no plans yeah so I
don't I guess I'm not supposed I can't
get it I can't there was a pregnant lady
who got it miscarried and it's they say
don't do this there was a story where it
was like in the United Kingdom
specifically they tell people if you're
pregnant don't take it if you have
allergies don't right right so I'll tell
you this
there's a story where it's like a woman
and she's like standing with her hands
on her hips and she's getting the
vaccine and she's 14 weeks pregnant and
then she posts two weeks later saying
This Is tragically miscarried and I feel
so bad for her sorry but like they
warned women who are pregnant not to
take the vaccine and they warn people
with food allergies not to do it so as
far as I'm concerned I'm gonna follow
those guidelines because a woman you
know miscarried seriously that's serious
a lot of people get too much into the
politics politics of it talk to your
doctors if your doctors tell you what
you should do you should do it and if
they're things things that are like
counter-indicated or they say you don't
do it for these reasons take it
seriously I'm not super worried we're
talking about herd immunity it means
there's a lot of people who have no
problem they're going to get the vaccine
they're going to be fine and I think a
couple million or whatever already have
Biden says gonna do his Mass rollout and
then we have herd immunity and not
everyone is going to get it I'm not
saying people should ignore it and not
get it I'm saying if you are pregnant if
you are nursing if you have allergies
you should follow those instructions and
I'm taking those seriously because I
don't want anaphylaxis I'm mean that
does not sound fun yeah the head of
Johnston and Johnson by the way is
saying that people should take the shot
once a year and they're going to have to
take it when it mutates and changes
there's also some news about rare blood
disorders that are coming up with some
people a lot of things we've got to get
into that we're going to talk about
later on yeah so I'm immunocompromised
and I probably will
worry about it until
I chill about it you know what I mean
yeah so turkey face says don't mind me
I'm just simping for Blair for Blair
white she's awesome heck yeah so many of
these comments I'm like passing because
it's just like people you know praising
glare okay well shout out to The One
Super Chat that made me think everyone
hated me in reality all these are like
positive things they love you you know I
I I I don't want to bring the negativity
but I also think if someone comments
something negative and I skip it because
they're saying something bad about
somebody and that's fake too yeah it's
fake it's fake but yeah but I gotta be
honest they're mostly praising you also
like
I don't know negativity doesn't deserve
to get propagated sometimes it's like if
you're damaging the system why would I
highlight you so I don't know I got
mixed feelings I used to want to show
everybody propagate everyone everyone
deserves a chance but Behavior certain
behaviors I don't I don't know then all
of a sudden I become the the hierarch
that decides what can and shouldn't
should and shouldn't be said so like
right deep conversation yeah
yeah Michael holder says I was going to
buy one of those space helmets to troll
my co-work co-workers and my manager
shut me down because it would affect my
peripheral vision no moral brow beating
morons for me sad troll noises I'm gonna
have fun I'm gonna take this thing out
to Walmart and I'm gonna give everyone
disgusted looks yes
not as good as me
I don't know why you're yelling at me
he'll totally lecture them and I have
two of them so like me and Ian can both
do it and just like the it's the best
thing you've hurt your signaling it
feels so good when you when you express
your moral superiority over your fellow
man imagine being able to physically
wear a space helmet and then just point
at people and yell that's amazing
remember in Invasion of the Body
Snatchers when what's his face
Sutherland Guy what's his first Donald
Sutherland yeah he goes
like points and yells we can do that
because you know what's funny is people
really do that like I see people that do
like the double mask and the face shield
and the goggles and they look at you
crazy they look at you like you're in
the crazy one Luke's got a funny meme
where it's a guy wearing sunglasses and
he's just he's thinking like that's
crazy and it's a guy wearing a mask and
a face shield getting anal swapped for a
covert test and he's thinking conspiracy
theorists but that's what they're doing
in China yeah they're butt swapping
people you know well hey you know
whatever nice of you
foreign
count Ludwig says I hate formal boycotts
but I think that's uh Free Speech lovers
must start organizing them against
companies that kowtow to cancel culture
in war the best funded organized Army
usually wins right now we're just
arranging a ragtag squad true
yep yep you vote with your dollar
exactly uh let's see
uh Robert boss as I went to DC from
Miami two days ago flight to DC had all
middle middle seats empty flight back
home to Miami all seats taken American
Airlines didn't let people on board in
bandanas masks only
interesting yeah they don't do bandanas
American's pretty bad with it that's
fair I get it yeah
Publius the good says well said Tim this
is the central issue the stimulus bills
have done virtually nothing for
individual people and massively
benefited corrupt corporations yup very
true
more people saying that they've canceled
their Disney plus I think it's the right
move because you know as long as
moderates disrespected liberals
conservatives whatever this pro-freedom
faction is as long as they're not going
to be organized and do anything that's
going to keep losing so you got to start
you know voting with your dollars man
you got to say no
right
keyboard Warrior says Tim what was the
military stealth radar you talked about
the other day that got recalled for too
many false positives what terms can I
Google for do you remember that it was
like a Quantum radar Quantum radar
that's what it was yeah the idea was
that it conduct invisible things in the
sky and it was giving too many readings
I guess too many false positives we
can't well I'll say this I haven't
looked into that story I don't know what
it's about yeah
it was too good so they pulled it off
the market and just told everyone that
it was malfunctioning but intrusive or
it was actually malfunctioning that was
my my conspiracy theory
caseto says here's money just because
you said the Book of Eli is a good movie
The Book of Eli is awesome very true
have you all have you all seen it you've
not seen it you'd love it it's great
it's really good yeah man that oh I
don't want to say anything I want to
spoil it now because Luke's not seeing
it it's awesome it's Denzel right Denzel
Washington yeah he's great it's
wait I thought it was Will Smith no no
no Denzel I guess it is Denzel yeah yeah
maybe maybe you're thinking of um iRobot
no I am Legend yeah yeah there you go
yeah I've seen both of those but similar
post-apocalyptic I Robot was gonna do so
yeah I think I Robot was awesome movies
suck now right seriously thank you oh
yeah Will Smith was in iRobot right yeah
I think that's one one of his best
movies it was good so good I kind of
want to watch it now yeah
Gareth green says Tim and Blair remember
Kilroy the meme oh the event
the Kilroy event remember that
do you remember that have I lost my mind
I don't know what that is they were
doing that sounds familiar but it was
like in Phoenix or whatever they were
going to do that event and then it fell
apart because oh
oh yeah that was a moment
indeed yeah that was a moment
one of those drama things that doesn't
matter the bigger the bigger world huh
yeah I see I forgot about it I'm like
what Doug Smith says Tim love your show
my wife and I are new business owners
opened a storefront February 2020 got
shut down still had to pay rent been
holding on but we haven't taken a
paycheck for a year how can we sponsor
you win win
um what's the store what do they do yeah
what's your well I don't know how you
talk about the responsible they could
probably message us through the email
and then info info timcast.com we could
figure out some kind of creative way to
help each other that would be great info
timcast.com I love it
Prometheus says no helmet but wearing a
mask is normal for many for many
motorcycle riders more specifically
Harley riders for bugs you see Luke you
were wrong you judged somebody and you
were wrong uh no this was like the the
medical mask I understand a bandana but
this was like maybe he was wearing it
because it served the purpose and when
it bugs in his mouth catch the bugs yeah
please wear a helmet he had no glasses
you're a bigot oh that's all it is
zix Captain LT IMT says hey hi Tim if
you need someone to do some character
voices for a satirical short I'd like to
try out for that can go high and low
from Ganondorf Ocarina of Time to Alvin
from Alvin and the Chipmunks Chipmunks
and higher and lower oh very interesting
very cool well once we start figuring
out what we're doing you know we'll
we'll do it to it are you taking
pictures I did a boomerang for Instagram
oh promoting yourself
Boomerang love it our Sean says everyone
watching right now should contact the
FTC and try and take take down
conglomerates on Google Facebook and
Twitter these companies will not be
nearly powerful they don't have
subsidiaries very true well file
complaints when you have legitimate
complaints for sure that's what their
agencies are for
Sparky the Pyro says mystery movie
theater 9000 timcast Edition when that
would be a lot of fun yeah that's great
but you can't you can't do it you can't
watch a movie and comment on it because
they take you down so boring
unless you like
you know what you do you record the
commentary and tell people
as at the at the zero zero Mark Press
Play oh yeah we could release a bunch of
those and you have a time stamp on it
and then what you do is you turn us on
while you watch the movie and you can
hear us talk about the movie and do
commentary that'd be fun right yeah
migno Solomon says I never understood
income tax basically the more productive
you are the more you pay versus sales
tax where the more you consume you pay
right if you use more resources you're
using more services that government
provides thoughts
um I like I have no problem with taxes I
have a problem with the corruption
so there's this really great meme posted
by this really brilliant independent
journalist where it said when
capitalists complain about socialism
they're complaining about government and
when socialists complain about
capitalism they're complaining about
government I can't I can't figure
remember the name of this this genius
independent journalist who opposes look
could you maybe know who who it was no
no no it was little
it was Luke no it's a good meme though
it's like
everybody the Socialists are like the
capitalists are doing this and that and
I'm like you're complaining about
corruption and then the capitalists like
the Socialists you're also complaining
about corruption right those titties
mean yeah yeah today's meme why you do
like one there's a lot of meat yeah
that's the main one for my Instagram
today meme of the day that's right of
the day
Steven Bigg says I write and have
directed several of my own movies if you
are seriously interested in making your
own shows I would be interested in
helping well jobs at timcast.com so
it'll probably you know light up but
there you go that's right
Aurora Diaz says Tim that's exactly
Mastered on social you could make at Tim
timcast.social and have a pod like email
has a domain and they connect together
well not Mastodon but the fediverse the
problem with Mastodon is their super
woke far left and they ban everybody so
the idea is to use something like the
feta verse which so we very male very
way very May well use fediverse uh
software beautiful so that we can all
link everything together yes all right
we'll just take uh maybe two more Super
chats we have this one from Hannah Choi
says how do you guys get your sources I
can never find good trustworthy sources
on Google by the way love you Blair uh I
just read multiple sources so I'll do a
search for a story and I'll see what
everybody's saying and then I'll look at
a right-wing source and a left-wing
source and then try and you know figure
out what the truth is at can I can I put
my two cents in because I use mimio
random
m-e-m-e random.com and they pull
everything together for you it's
fantastic I really love it it's like
everything it's completely unbiased I
love it nice is it no no Luke you don't
have any sources fact checked fact check
everything and uh make sure there's
actually evidence behind it look at the
documents look at the photos look at
who's cooperating it look at the
witnesses is it an anonymous source well
there's reason to be skeptical if it is
thank you all right we'll do one last
Super Chat from Ed S he says Blair is
hot oh there's just a lot of them sorry
yeah that's the finale finale super
chats so ladies and gentlemen we're
going to do a bonus segment it's gonna
be for members only over at timcast.com
so make sure you go there and sign up if
you want to hear us talk all this crazy
stuff that would probably get us banned
off social media it's gonna be good and
there's even a shout out to all the
grifters who signed up to become members
and have given us your emails and IPS
and all that stuff to just download our
clips and post them all over the
Internet which is just free promotion so
it is what it is that's right I think
the craziest thing is there are people
who like you know clip the the private
stuff it's like you gave us all your
private information you know what I mean
like why would you do that right and
isn't it technically illegal no I mean
there's there's there's some uh it's a
civil case if they take proprietary
behind the pay wall and start leaking at
stuff oh actually that might be yeah
because there's people that take like
people's maybe a patreon exclusive
content and you can actually go after
them really um
well anyway become a member if you look
yeah do you want to just watch the
content which is available on the site
and uh we'll have that segment coming up
in maybe about an hour or so but don't
forget to check out my other YouTube
channels youtube.com timcast youtube.com
timcast news we do the show Monday
through Friday live at 8pm so subscribe
hit that notification Bell smash that
like button if you haven't already if
you're listening on the podcast to make
sure you leave us a good review and a
comment and you can follow me on in no
you know what you can follow me on mines
that's right mines.com Tim cast to where
my videos are automatically posted and
I'll start posting more there instead of
these other garbage platforms but uh
Blair you want to mention your social
media or anything yeah please subscribe
to me on YouTube to search up Blair
white I'm the only Blair white
um I'm on Twitter Instagram it's Blair
with an E everyone forgets that yeah
just search me up anywhere I'm
everywhere right on if we're getting
into entertainment sorry I just want to
kind of go off on a tangent here if
we're going to go off to entertainment
my pitch is to get someone like Tim
Dylan Ryan long JP Spears Joey B Toons
what's her face and let's create a new
kind of mad tv satirical comedy to make
fun of the establishment until they're
so embarrassed they don't even want to
go outside that would be my pitch I
would love to see that that just my idea
a little brain fart I had to get out
that I was kind of formulating here as
well they're all inviting uh they're all
invited I love all of those guys uh and
girls that you do they do incredible
work check them out if you're interested
and if you want to check me out and
support me you can on we are change.org
forward slash donate there's many
different ways you could get involved
with what I'm doing but mainly I just
released videos on youtube.com forward
slash we are change we are change is the
YouTube channel and thanks for checking
me out on there and you guys can follow
me at Ian Crossland uh hit me up on
Twitch or follow me there at Ian cross
on it's twitch.tv Ian Crossland and you
can also follow me on mines
I love that website very at Ian
Crossland
I'm on mines too I forgot yeah she is
she is for sure for sure follow Minds
for sure I am Lydia I am sour patchlitz
on Twitter I'm also on mines and I'm
real Sour Patch Lids on Instagram and
gab just so you guys know ladies and
gentlemen thank you all so much for
hanging out for this episode of the
timcast IRL podcast I hope you check out
timcast.com because we will have a
special members only segment coming up
in about an hour or so for all of you
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all there bye guys bye